ASSEMBLY COMMITTEES. ON BUDGET
TO ORDER. SO WE ARE THE
PANELISTS WILL BE- APPEARING
REMOTELY THERE WILL BE NO
VOTING COMMITTEE TODAY WE ARE
ACCEPTING PUBLIC COMMENT AT THE
END OF THE HEARING BOTH IN THE
HEARING ROOM AS WELL AS ON THE
PHONE. THE PUBLIC TOLL FREE
NUMBER IS. 877-692-8957 THE
PUBLIC ACCESS CODE IS. ONE
THREE ONE FIVE FOUR FOUR THREE
SEVEN OF THAT NUMBER SHOULD BE
ON TV OR IF YOU GO TO THE
ASSEMBLY BUDGET COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. IS ON THERE AS WELL
YOU CAN CALL THE COMMITTEE
FIFTY ANY ISSUES AT.
916-319-2099 WE CURRENTLY HAVE
NINE BILLS BEFORE THE COMMITTEE
TODAY. MISS ERIKA LEE WITH
PARMA FINANCIAL PRESENT ALL OF
THESE IT THAN FIFTY GATHER AND-
MISTER DAVE PADDOCK LEGISLATIVE
ANALYSTS WILL BE AVAILABLE FOR
ANY QUESTIONS WE WILL THEN TAKE
MEMBER QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS
AGAIN THERE'S NO VOTING
COMMITTEE TODAY. AND WE INTEND
TO TAKE UP THESE BILLS AS LONG
AS WELL AS AB ONE THIRTY TO THE
HIGHER EDUCATION- BILL. ON THE
FLOOR ON THURSDAY. WITHOUT
LET'S GO TO MISLEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON- CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE I'M GLAD TO BE
HERE TO PRESENT ON THE PACKAGE
OF TRAILER BILLS- LAST EVENING
THE GOVERNOR SIGNED SB ONE
TWENTY NINE WOULD PROVIDE THE
OVERALL ARCHITECTURE FOR THE
BUDGET AGREEMENT BETWEEN THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR
AND REFLECTS CALIFORNIA SHARED
PRIORITIES ENSURE VALUES. AFTER
MANY DISCUSSIONS OVER MANY
MONTHS AND WEEKS- I AM PLEASED
TO PRESENT ON THE FINAL DETAILS
OF THE BUDGET AGREEMENT THAT
ARE INCLUDED IN TODAY'S TRAILER
BILL AND THE BUDGET BILL JUNIOR
THE FINAL BUDGET INCLUDES
INVESTMENTS IN CHILD CARE AND
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN
INCREASES FOR HIGHER EDUCATION
BASED AND HEALTH CARE ACCESS
AND AFFORDABILITY. INCREASES
THE SERVICES FOR CALIFORNIANS
WITH DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
MAJOR SERVICE EXPANSIONS TO
HELP OUR FAMILIESBACK ON THEIR
FEET AT THE COURTS FOR AGING
CALIFORNIANS. AMONG MANY OTHER
IMPORTANT INVESTMENTS. BUDGET
ALSO PRESENTS LARGEST RECOVERY
PACKAGE IN THE COUNTRY
PROVIDING STIMULUS PAYMENTS. TO
MIDDLE CLASS CALIFORNIANS
IMMEDIATE RELIEF FOR SMALL
BUSINESSES. SUPPORT THE
TRANSFORMATION OF OUR PUBLIC
SCHOOLS TACKLE THE HOMELESSNESS
CRISIS HEAD ON AND MAKE MAJOR
INVESTMENTS IN CLIMATE CHANGE.
CLIMATE CHANGE ACTIONS AND WILL
CONTINUE THAT THOSE DISCUSSIONS
THROUGHOUT THE SUMMER- AND THE
CLIMATE RELATED PACKAGES. WITH
FACTS I WILL BEGIN THE
PRESENTATION ON THE FIRST OF
NINE BILLS AB S. B. ONE THIRTY
ONE EARLY EDUCATION. OUT OF THE
BILL INCLUDES PROVISIONS
RELATED TO CHILDCARE PROVIDER
RATE CHILD CARE SLOTS THE CHILD
CARE PANDEMIC RELIEF PACKAGE
FUNDED BY FEDERAL FUNDS. AND
INFRASTRUCTURE GRANTS FOR CHILD
CARE FACILITIES SPECIFICALLY
THE BILL INCLUDES INCREASES TO
THE REGIONAL MARKET RATES TO
THE SEVENTY FIFTH PERCENTILE OF
THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN. OUR OF OUR
SURVEY HEALTH ACTIVE JANUARY
FIRST OF NEXT YEAR. IT
INCREASES THE STANDARD
REIMBURSEMENT RATES OR S. R. R.
FOR PROVIDERS INCLUDING FOR
CHILD CARE AND PRESCHOOL. WITH
A FOUR POINT 005% COST OF
LIVING ADJUSTMENT ADDS UP JULY
THIS YEAR- IT BRINGS ALL
LICENSE EXEMPT PROVIDERS
RECEIVING EXCEPT A SUBSIDY 270%
OF THE LICENSED FAMILY CHILD
CARE HOME RATE FEELING
EFFECTIVE JANUARY ONE OF NEXT
YEAR. THE BILL EXPANDS CHILD
CARE ACCESS BY ADDING OVER A
HUNDRED FORTY FIVE THOUSAND NEW
CHILD CARE SLOTS BY TWENTY
TWENTY. TWENTY TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE AND AN ADDITIONAL
TWENTY THOUSAND NEW SLOTS.
ANNUALLY THROUGH TWENTY FIVE
TWENTY SIX. BOB ASSUMING THE
STATE'S ECONOMIC CONDITIONS
SUPPORT THAT. AND THE BILL
ALLOCATES FIVE HUNDRED SEVENTY
NINE MILLION FEDERAL FUNDS TO
CHILD CARE AND PRESCHOOL
PROVIDERS PURSUANT TO THE APRIL
CHILD CARE PROVIDERS. UNITED
AGREEMENT- FOR THE BILL
PROVIDES GREAT SUPPLEMENTS
PROVIDERS A JOINT TRAINING AND
EDUCATION PARTNERSHIP FUND. AND
INCENTIVES. TO RETAIN LICENSED
PROVIDERS. ARE MOVING ON TO THE
NEXT TRAILER BILL AB S. B. ONE
THIRTY THREE THE HEALTH TRAILER
BILL- BUT AMENDMENTS TO ONE
THIRTY THREE- WHAT WAS HEARD
LAST WEEK SORRY AMENDMENTS TO
AB S. B. ONE THIRTY THREE WHICH
WAS HER LAST WEEK- IT DURING
FULL BUDGET HEARINGS INCLUDE
ESTABLISHING AN INNOVATIVE AND
PREVENTION FOCUS BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH SYSTEM WHERE ALL
CHILDREN AND YOUTH. TWENTY FIVE
YEARS OF AGE OR YOUNGER ARE
ROUTINELY SCREENED SUPPORTED
AND SERVED FOR EMERGING AND
EXISTING BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
NEEDS REGARDLESS A PAIR. OF THE
BILL EXPANDS THE COMMUNITY
CONTINUUM OF BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
TREATMENT RESOURCES BY
PROVIDING GRANTS TO QUALIFIED
ENTITIES TO CONSTRUCT THE CHOIR
AND REHABILITATE REAL. ESTATE
ASSETS ARE TO INVEST IN A
MOBILE CRISIS INFRASTRUCTURE.
IT REMOVES- THE MEDIC HOW RATE
FREEZE AN INTERMEDIATE CARE
FACILITIES FOR THE
DEVELOPMENTALLY DISABLED AND
FREESTANDING PEDIATRIC SUB
ACUTE FACILITIES. R. BECOMING
THE WORKER LED BY THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY TO IDENTIFY
SHORT MEDIUM AND LONG TERM
DELIVERABLES TO RESOLVE THE
INCOMPETENT TO STAND TRIAL
PRICES. BY NOVEMBER THIRTIETH
OF THIS YEAR. AND AUTHORIZES
THE DEPARTMENT IS UP TO
CONTRACTORS OF THE KEYPAD
CAPACITY TO ADDRESS THE
INCREASING NUMBER OF
INCOMPETENT TO STAND TRIAL
PATIENT REFERRALS TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF STATE HOSPITALS.
UP AND THIS BILL INCLUDES
THIRTEEN MILLION I'M GOING TO
ENTER A FUND TO SUPPORT
INVESTMENTS AND EPIDEMICS OF
HIV AIDS HEPATITIS C. AND
SEXUALLY TRANSMITTED INFECTIONS.
WE'VE GOT TO THE THIRD TRAILER
BILL- AB- SP ONE THIRTY FIVE
HUMAN SERVICES- THIS BILL AS
PART OF THE TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO BUDGET PACKAGE MAKE
STATUTORY CHANGES TO IMPLEMENT
THE BUDGET ACT SPECIFICALLY IT
INCLUDES PROVISIONS PERTAINING
TO- HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
INCLUDING HOME SAFE. AND
HOUSING A DISABILITY ADVOCACY
PROGRAM. OF MEDICAID PROVISIONS
PERTAINING TO THE SUPPLEMENTAL
SECURITY INCOME STATE
SUPPLEMENTAL PAYMENT OR ALSO
KNOWN AS S. AS I. S. IS P. AND
TO THE IN HOME SUPPORTIVE.
SERVICES PROGRAM FOR IHS US. I
THINK THIS PROVISIONS
PERTAINING TO POWER- INCLUDING
A FOR A FIVE POINT 3% INCREASE
TO THE CALPERS MAXIMUM. AID
PAYMENT AND FOR THAT FOR
HUNDRED FOUR MILLION FEDERAL
PANDEMIC EMERGENCY ASSISTANCE
FUND TEN AFTER PROVIDE ONE TIME
CASH PAYMENTS- CAL WORKS
FAMILIES. IT ALSO INCLUDES
PROVISIONS PERTAINING TO
CALFRESH AND FOOD PROGRAMS-
INCLUDING THE FACT EXPANSION
FOODBANK RESOURCES. OF WOULD BE
CAPACITY IN CLIMATE RESILIENCE
THANK BURBANK FUNDING- AND IT'S
ALL THE SHOULD THE CALIFORNIA
ORIGINALLY PAYMENT PROGRAM
UTILIZING A BILLION DOLLARS
FROM THE FEDERAL ARE BOTH.
MOVING ONTO AB AT THE ONE FORTY
HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS
HOMELESSNESS FOR THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE BUDGET ACT INCLUDES
A HISTORIC HOMELESSNESS PACKAGE
OF. ELEVEN POINT EIGHT BILLION
OVER TWO YEARS THAT MAKES
INVESTMENT DIRECT COMPREHENSIVE
APPROACH OF HOUSING AND
SERVICES ACROSS A RANGE OF
HOMELESSNESS INTERVENTIONS. TO
REBUILD CALIFORNIA'S BEHAVIOR
HEALTH HOUSING SYSTEM EXPAND
ACCESS TO AFFORDABLE HOUSING
ASSIST LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
DEVELOP AND CHAPMAN AT
RESTRAINT USE AND PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES FOR HUNKY.
OF IT ALSO INCLUDES TEN BILLION
HOUSING- EIGHT EIGHT TEN
BILLION HOUSING PACKAGE TO
PROMOTE AND MAINTAIN STABLE
HOUSING THROUGH ADDITIONAL AND
EXPANDED RENTAL ASSISTANCE
FORECLOSURE PREVENTION MORTGAGE
ASSISTANCE AND FIRST TIME
HOMEOWNER INVESTMENTS- AB SB
ONE FORTY PROVIDES A STATUTORY
FRAMEWORK FOR THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF A SIGNIFICANT
PORTION OF THOSE INVESTMENTS
THAT I JUST MENTIONED. AND I'LL
JUST HIGHLIGHT A FEW- IN
HOMELESSNESS HOMELESSNESS
THERE'S TWO POINT TWO BILLION
OF FEDERAL ARPA- TO CONTINUE
HUNKY ACQUISITIONS- FIFTY
MILLION ONE TIME GENERAL FUND
FOR THE ESTABLISHMENT OF BEING.
CALVET RESOLUTION FUNDING
PROGRAM- THAT WAS FAR
HOMELESSNESS FOR HOUSING SOME
NOTABLE- PROVISIONS ARE THE
BILL PERMITS EACH TV TO PROVIDE
LOANS OR GRANTS TO SHOVEL READY
PROJECTS THAT HAVE SUCCESSFULLY
ACQUIRED HCV FUNDING TO
EXPEDITE THE CONSTRUCTION AND
PRODUCTION OF PORTABLE HOUSING.
IN LIEU OF WAITING FOR A STATE
TAX CREDIT- TO BE AVAILABLE
WHICH COULD TAKE MANY YEARS.
AND THE BUDGET ACT PROVIDED ONE
POINT SEVEN FIVE BILLION IN.
FEDERAL FUNDS FOR THESE
EFFORTS- ANOTHER NOTABLE
PROVISION IS SIX HUNDRED
MILLION FOR THE NEWLY
ESTABLISHED REGIONAL EARLY
ACTION PLANNING GRANTS OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TO PROVIDE
ONE TIME GRANTS TO REGIONAL
ENTITIES TO FIND. SUSTAINABLE
HOUSING GOALS AND ALSO RESULT
REDUCE PER CAPITA VEHICLE MILES
TRAVELED. AB MOVING ONTO AB AT
THE ONE FORTY EIGHTH THE
RESOURCES TRAILER BILL. UNDER
THE BILL MAKES VARIOUS CHANGES
RELATED TO PUBLIC RESOURCES
INCLUDING BUT NOT LIMITED TO
PROVIDING FLEXIBILITY AS TAX
RIGHT CLICKING FOR AREAS
EXPERIENCING DROUGHT
CONDITIONS. ESTABLISHING
GUIDELINES FOR THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
CALIFORNIA WATER AND WASTEWATER
RAGE PAYMENT PROGRAM. MAKING
TECHNICAL CHANGES NEEDED TO
ESTABLISH THE OFFICE OF ENERGY
INFRASTRUCTURE SAFETY- WHICH IS
THE SUCCESSOR AGENCY TO THE
WELFARE SAFETY DIVISION THAT
WAS ESTABLISHED IN JANUARY OF
TWENTY TWENTY AT THE QC. OF THE
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION.
AND LASTLY ESTABLISHES A
CALIFORNIA STATE PARK ADVENTURE
PATH OF PILOT PROGRAM WHICH
PERMITS ANY CHILD IN THE FOURTH
GRADE OR FOURTH GRADE
EQUIVALENT AND THEIR FAMILIES
WHO ARE CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS
THE ABILITY TO VISIT. ELIGIBLE
STATE PARK STATE PARKS. I'M
MOVING ON TO AB ARE AT THE ONE
FIFTY THREE CHILD WELFARE. THIS
BILL AS PART OF THE TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO BUDGET PACKAGE MAKES
APPETITE CHANGES TO IMPLEMENT
THE BUDGET ACT SPECIFICALLY THE
BILL INCLUDES PROVISIONS
PERTAINING TO CHILD WELFARE
SERVICES. ADMINISTERED AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
WHICH INCLUDES- I DON'T THINK
COMPLEX CARE NEEDS FOR FOSTER
YOUTH FAMILY REUNIFICATION CAL
WORKS ASSISTANCE PAYMENT FAMILY
FIRST PREVENTION SERVICES. OF A
FOSTER CARE EMERGENCY.
ASSISTANCE AND EMERGENCY
RESPONSE SOCIAL WORKERS- OTHER
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTSARE THE
GUARANTEED INCOME PILOT PROGRAM
WHICH WAS FUNDED AT THIRTY FIVE
MILLION. AND- THE BUDGET.
MOVING ON TO A. B. S. B. ONE
FIFTY SIX THE BROADBAND TRAILER
BILL OF THIS BILL REFLECTS THE
STATEWIDE BROADBAND PLAN TO
ACHIEVE EQUITABLE STATEWIDE
ACCESS TO THE HIGH SPEED TO
HIGH SPEED BROADBAND INTERNET
SERVICE AND PROPOSES SIX
BILLION DOLLARS TO INVESTIGATE
AND BROADWAY BROADBAND
INFRASTRUCTURE AND ENHANCE
ACCESS BY CONSTRUCTING AN OPEN
ACCESS MIDDLE MILE NETWORK. AND
BY FUNDING CONSTRUCTION OF LAST
MILE PROJECTS TO SPECIFICALLY
THIS BILL PROVIDES TWO BILLION
TO THE- TO BE ALLOCATED THROUGH
THE EXISTING CALIFORNIA
ADVANCED SERVICES FUND
ALTERNATIVE CONCEPTS- TO BUILD
BROADBAND INFRASTRUCTURE
PROJECTS FOR COMMUNITIES TO
CONNECT TO WHAT IS CALLED THE
MIDDLE MILE OR THE STATE'S.
INTERNET BACKBONE A BILLION
WILL BE FOR RURAL AREAS AND
ANOTHER BILLION WILL BE FOR
URBAN AREAS. IT PROVIDES FOR
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY IN THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION. TO
CONTRACT WITH A THIRD PARTY
ADMINISTRATOR- SOMEWHAT SOME
ENTITY WITH DEEP EXPERIENCE IN
BUILDING. A NETWORK- AND WILL
WORK WITH THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY AND-
PC TO LOCATE AND TO FIND THE
MIDDLE MILE INFRASTRUCTURE.
PRIMARILY ON STATE OWNED- RIGHT
TO BLAME- IT ALSO ESTABLISHES A
BROADBAND ADVISORY COMMITTEE
COMPOSED OF REPRESENTATIVES
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY DO YOU SEE CALTRANS
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
GOVERNMENT OPERATIONS AGENCY
AND FOR ACTIVISTS CO MEMBERS
APPOINTED BY THE ASSEMBLY AND
SENATE. OTHER BROADBAND FUNDS
THAT ARE NECESSARY FOR THE
STATE'S BROADBAND PLAN ARE
INCLUDED IN THE BJ'S- WHICH I
WILL BE PRESENTING AND LATER
BUT FOR PURPOSES OF THIS
TRAILER BILL- WANTED TO ADD
THREE POINT TWO FIVE BILLION
WILL BE. FOR STATE OWNED OPEN
ACCESS MIDDLE MILE TWO BILLION
TO FUND THE LAST MILE- WHICH IS
WHAT I PREVIOUSLY MENTIONED AND
THEN SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION FOR A LOAN LOSS RESERVE
ACCOUNT WITH THE CALIFORNIA.
ADVANCED SERVICES FUND TO HELP
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS SECURE FINANCING
FOR CONSTRUCTION OF LAST MILE
BROADBAND INFRASTRUCTURE.
MOVING ON TO AB SB ONE SIXTY
THE CANNABIS CLEAN UP TRAILER
BILL- THIS BILL AMONG OTHER
PROVISIONS MAKES CHANGES TO
EIGHTY ONE FORTY ONE WHICH
ESTABLISHED THE DEPARTMENT. OF
CANNABIS CONTROL AND INCLUDES
COMPONENTS THAT ADDRESS
PROVISIONAL LICENSE TIMELINE
AND TRADE SAMPLES AMONG OTHER
ISSUES PHYSICALLY. IT
CLARIFIES. OUR SUBSEQUENT
RENEWALS FOR ALL PROVISIONAL
LICENSEES. LICENSES HOW TO
DEMONSTRATE COMPLIANCE WITH
EQUAL FOR LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
THAT HAVE MADE AGREEMENTS AND
SEEK A COMPLIANCE WITH THE
STATE OR NOT ENVISIONED WITHIN
AB ONE FORTY ONE. SPECIFIES
THAT IF THE LEAD AGENCY
COMPLIES WITH THE QUOTE THEY
ARE NOT SUBJECT TO COMPLY WITH
THE COURT BENCHMARKS INCLUDED
IN THIS BILL- I LAUGH WITH
THEIR BY THE JULY ONE TWENTY
TWENTY THREE IS. THE DATE WHEN
THE CONDITIONS GOING TO A FACT
FOR SUBSEQUENT RENEWALS. FOR
ALL PROVISIONAL LICENSES. AND
IT'S TO THE LAST BILL AB SB ONE
SIXTY FOUR. WHICH IS THE BUDGET
BILL JUNIOR AND AMEND THE
ENACTED BUDGET- THIS BILL GETS
TECHNICAL IN CLARIFYING CHANGES
TO VARIOUS ITEMS IN THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE BUDGET ACT
INCLUDING- INCLUDING PROVIDES
AN EXTENDED COMMENT PERIOD FOR
A ONE TIME FUNDS APPROPRIATED.
IN THE TWENTY ONE BUDGET ACT
FOR UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
STUDENT ACADEMIC PREPARATION
EDUCATIONAL PARTNERSHIPS- THE
BILL AUTHORIZES THE ARTS
COUNCIL TO ENTER INTO A ONE
TIME CONTRACT FOR UP TO FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND. TO ESTABLISH
A NONPROFIT CAME AFTER TO
PROVIDE LOW COST PAYROLL
SERVICES TO SMALL NONPROFIT
ARTS ORGANIZATIONS. PROVIDE
TECHNICAL CLEANUP OR EDITS TO
THE COURTS BUDGET THE
DEPARTMENT OF CANNABIS CONTROL
THE WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARD
AND THE DEPARTMENT. OF
INDUSTRIALIZATION. AND AS
PREVIOUSLY MENTIONED IT
INCLUDES- THE BROADBAND
PACKAGE- OF A SIX BILL UP THERE
TWENTY FIVE BILLION FOR MIDDLE
MILE AND SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY
BILLION FOR LOAN LOSS RESERVE
ACCOUNT. WITH FACT- I THAT IS
NOT THE END STATION ON THE NINE
BILLS AND I'M HAPPY TO TURN IT
OVER TO- MISTER PECK FOR ANY
QUESTIONS OR TO- MY COLLEAGUES
AT THE CUP- COMMITTEE HAS ANY
QUESTIONS. YOU'VE GOT TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE. MR
FOR TH I THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR- WELL THIS RUN TO LIKE
LAST TIME AT THE THROUGH THE
BILLS AND- HE COULD HAVE FOLKS
ANSWER- WITH ANY ERA. CLARITY
HOPEFULLY- IN TERMS OF SB ONE
THIRTY ONE- IS IT IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT MOST OF THE-
CHECKERS LOTS. ARE ARE FUNDED
THROUGH FEDERAL FUNDS IS THAT
CORRECT. WITH THAT WITH A MIX
OF THE STATE FUNDS TERRIFIED.
YES THERE ARE THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION MR FONG- THERE ARE A
MAKES A FINE STEP ON THE SLOTS
AND SPECIFICALLY OPEN FOR THAT
OVER TO MY COLLEAGUE HI
JENNIFER LOPEZ WITH. GOOD
AFTERNOON JENNIFER LOPEZ
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THAT IS
CORRECT- PORTION OF THE SPONSOR
FUNDED WITH FEDERAL FUNDING AND
IN GENERAL FUNDS. OKAY BUT IS
THAT. BY THE FOR THE FEDERAL
FUNDING MAKES UP MOST OF THEM
HAVE I THINK A SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNT OF THE CHILD CARE SLOTS
IS THAT CORRECT. THAT IS
CORRECT APPROXIMATELY THREE
QUARTERS OF THE FUNDING AND
BUDGET YEAR IS FUNDED WITH
FEDERAL FUNDING OKAY. SO I'VE
**** AND IN OTHER BRIEFINGS BUT
I'D LIKE TO GET THE DEPARTMENT
YOU'RE A PART FINANCES
PERSPECTIVE SO- IT IT STARTS
OUT. WITH A HUNDRED TWENTY
THOUSAND SLOTS IN APRIL TWENTY
TWENTY TWO AND THEN ADDS TWENTY
THOUSAND SLOTS IN EACH
SUBSEQUENT YEAR. THE FUNDING.
FOR THIS BILL IS FOR TWO YEARS
IS THAT CORRECT SO WHAT IS THE
FUNDING SOURCE IS FOR THE- FOR
THE ADDITIONAL YEARS TO GET THE
TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND IS THERE
GOING TO BE A COMMITMENT AT THE
GENERAL FUND. FROM THE STATE-
AND WHAT IS THAT WHAT IS THE
SOURCE OF THOSE FUNDING THAT
FOR THE FUNDING STREAM MOVING
FORWARD. MOST DEFINITELY
JENNIFER LOPEZ DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE SO IN REGARDS SO IT
WOULD KIND OF LOOK AT THE TWO
FOLD SO THE ADMINISTRATION AND
THE MAY REVISION INITIALLY
PROPOSED A HUNDRED THOUSAND
SPOTS. OF THOSE A HUNDRED
THOUSAND SLOTS THIRTY FIVE
THOUSAND WOULD BE FUNDED
THROUGH GENERAL FUND FROM
BUDGET YEAR ALL THE WAY ON
THROUGH THE MULTI YEAR. IN
REGARDS TO THE ADDITIONAL
TWENTY THOUSAND SLOTS WE HAVE
MADE A COMMITMENT TO PROVIDE
INCREASED LOTS ON AN ANNUAL
BASIS SUBJECT TO THE STATE'S
ECONOMIC CONDITION I'M ASSUMING
THAT THE STATE CAN ACT ECONOMIC
CONDITION CAN CONTINUE TO
SUPPORT THE OUT YOUR GROWTH WE
ARE SENDING TWENTY THOUSAND
SLOTS WILL BE ADDED ANNUALLY.
IN ADDITION TO THE SPOT SEAT
MINISTRATION PROPOSED IN THE
MAY REVISION THROUGH TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY FIVE TWENTY
SIX. OKAY SO JUST USING THE
ROUGH NUMBERS AND OF COURSE IF
THE ABOUT SPECIFICS- CERTAINLY
HAPPY TO HAVE THEM- SO YOU
PROBABLY IN THE NEXT TWO YEARS
THERE'S FUNDING FOR THE ONE
TWENTY AND UNDER TWENTY
THOUSAND SLOTS AND THEN
PROBABLY ADDITIONAL TWENTY
THOUSAND THE FOLLOWING YEAR.
AND FORTY THOUSAND JUST BECAUSE
THE BILL HAS TWO YEARS OF
FUNDING AND THEN FOLLOWING
THAT. THE ONE HUNDRED FORTY
THOUSAND THAT IS THE
INDEPENDENT ON. THE ECONOMIC
OUTLOOK AND THE AMOUNT OF
REVENUE THAT THE STATE HAS TO
WHETHER YOU CAN HIT. ANOTHER.
TWENTY THOUSAND FOR EACH
SUBSEQUENT YEAR. THAT IS. OKAY
SO AM I DON'T WANT TO GET MY
CORRECT TO NOT ASSUME BUT TO
SAY THAT HER FORTY THOUSAND FOR
SURE AND THEN MOVING FORWARD
HOPEFULLY HIGHER. CORRECT OKAY-
IN TERMS OF A MOVING TO AT WORK
SB ONE THIRTY THREE THE HEALTH
CARE- THE BILL- IN TERMS OF THE
DATA EXCHANGE FRAMEWORK THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT WILL BE CREATED
AND MAINTAINED BY. DCHS IS THAT
CORRECT. AND NOT THE
PHARMACOLOGY OR ANYTHING ELSE
THAT'S IT THAT'S IT THAT WILL
BE MAINTAINED BY THAT AGENCY.
IT WILL BE MAINTAINED BY THE-
CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY AND- THIS IS
WHEN I LOOK AT MY TICKETS WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
APART THE AND WHAT DO THEY HAVE
THE CAPACITY TO CREATE IN.
GENERATE AND MAINTAIN THIS-
THIS PRETTY SUBSTANTIAL NEW- I.
T. SYSTEM. SO THE TWO POINT
FIVE MILLION- ONE TIME GENERAL
FUND INCLUDED IN THE BUDGET IS-
TO GET- THE YOU KNOW TO START
ORGANIZING THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF THE HEALTH INFORMATION
EXCHANGE AND THAT'S AVAILABLE
FOR EXPECT EXPENDITURE FOR
THREE YEARS. OKAY. AND WE SOLD
WILL BE SAID THAT HHS WILL GO
OUT AND SEE CONTRACTS. TO
DEVELOP THIS IDEA THAT THIS THE
DATA EXCHANGE. SO IT IT'LL BE A
PROCESS SO THERE WILL BE A
STAKEHOLDER ADVISORY GROUP-
THAT WILL SORT OF- LOOK AT HOW
BEST TO IMPLEMENT THIS- AND
THEN IT ON JANUARY FIRST OF
TWENTY TWENTY THREE THERE WILL
BE A- SINGLE DATA SHARING
AGREEMENT THAT WILL BE-
DEVELOPED- SO THE ACTUAL- DATA
SHARING WON'T HAPPEN UNTIL. I
THINK FOR AYE ONCE WE'VE OTHER
MEMBERS BUT I. T. IS SIR
CERTAINLY A CONCERN WHEN IT
COMES TO- TO A NUMBER OF
AGENCIES- SO I THINK THE
CAPACITY AND CAPABILITIES ARE
SELLING SOMETHING THAT WE NEED
TO- TO MONITOR- JUMPING TO THE-
THE I. S. T. DEFENDANTS- ISSUE
IF I COUNTY IS UNABLE TO- TO
TAKE- TO TAKE RESPONSIBILITY
FOR A DEFENDANT WHO IS
INCOMPETENT TO STAND TRIAL DO
THEY HAVE AN OPTION TO WORK
WITH A NEIGHBORING COUNTY HOW
DOES THAT HOW DOES THIS
AGREEMENT- OPERATE I KNOW THAT-
MY COLLEAGUE- FROM THE EAST BAY
HAD SIMILAR CHALLENGES ENGINE
CONCERNS. SO WHAT WHAT'S HE
AGREEMENT HOW DOES IT OPERATE I
HAVE THE SAME CONCERNS HERE IN
KERN COUNTY. AFTERNOON I JUST
THINK IT'S WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE SO IF A FELONY
INCOMPETENT TO STAND TRIAL
PATIENT OR A DEFENDANT WHO HAS.
COMMITTED A FELONY I'M WHO IS
DEEMED INCOMPETENT TO STAND
TRIAL IS THE RESPONSIBILITY OF
THE STATE. AND I BE ON THE
STATE OF DEPARTMENT OF STATE
HOSPITALS SO- ESSENTIALLY SO IF
IT'S A- A MISDEMEANOR I S. T.
THAT WOULD BE THAT THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF THE COUNTIES.
AND IN TERMS OF INTERCOUNTY
AGREEMENTS FOR A MISDEMEANOR.
AT PATIENTS I CAN FIND MORE
INFORMATION OUT ABOUT THAT AND
GET BACK TO YOU- AND PROMPTLY
IF THAT WOULD WORK FOR YOU OKAY
SO SAID THE PUSH OR THE EFFORT
TO MOVE- INDIVIDUALS FROM STATE
HOSPITALS TO COUNTY FACILITIES.
THAT IS THAT STILL PROCEEDING
AND THEN HOW IS THAT ADDRESSED-
WITH THE LANGUAGE IN THE BUDGET
TRAILER BILL. I KNOW GALGIANI
IS A CONCERN ABOUT THAT I'M
SORRY. NO OF COURSE- SO I JUST
THINK IT'S WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE AGAIN SO THE BUDGET
INCLUDES RESOURCES FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF STATE HOSPITALS
TO CONTRACT FOR SUB ACUTE BED
CAPACITY WILL BE WORKING WITH
OF LOCAL GOVERNMENTS PARTNERS-
WHICH COULD BE A PUBLIC OR
PRIVATE IN ORDER TO- YOU KNOW
EXPAND OUR BED CAPACITY. SO TO
BE WORKING WITH THE OTHER
COUNTIES- TO DO THAT AND IT'S
WHERE- IF THERE'S ALSO GOING TO
BE A WORKGROUP- TO FIND
SOLUTIONS TO THE I. S. T.
PATIENT WEIGHTLESS PROBLEM SO
THERE WILL BE OF LONG TERM
MEDIUM TERM AND SHORT TERM
SOLUTIONS IDENTIFIED IN THAT
WORK GROUP. AND IN ORDER AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENT PARTNERS WILL
BE- INCLUDED IN THAT PROCESS
OKAY SO WHAT WITH THE FUNDING
BE USED SUPPORT FOR THE FOR
THIS YEAR AS CURRENT YEAR WOULD
THAT BE TO CONTRACT WITH COUNTY
FACILITIES. EXISTING CAN IF IT
LOOKS. IT COULD BE COUNTY
FACILITIES- IT COULD BE
INSTITUTIONS FOR MENTAL DISEASE
OUR MENTAL HEALTH
REHABILITATION CENTERS OR
SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES FOR
EXAMPLE. OKAY I THINK THIS IS
AN AREA CERTAINLY THAT WE'RE
GONNA HAVE TO WATCH VERY
CLOSELY I'M I'M CERTAINLY
CONCERNED THAT THERE'S GONNA BE
ADDITIONAL MANDATES ON THE
COUNTIES- AND I WOULD LOVE TO
HAVE THE INFORMATION IN TERMS
OF IF THE COUNTY DOESN'T HAVE
CAPACITY. HOW THAT POPULATION
GETS- ADDRESS WHETHER IT'S
PARTNERING WITH THAT A
NEIGHBORING COUNTY- IN TERMS OF
THE HOUSING BILL WHEN IT COMES
TO THE HOMELESSNESS FUNDING-
THE FORMULA THAT'S PROVIDED.
WHAT PERCENTAGE OF IT GOES TO
URBAN CITIES AND WHAT
PERCENTAGE GOES TO RURAL
COMMUNITIES DO WE HAVE DO YOU
HAVE THAT BREAK DOWN. TWO OF.
MY SELF THANK YOU. BRAZIL THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- THERE
ARE SOME MONEY ASIDE FOR THE
THIRTEEN LARGEST URBAN CITIES-
AND- I DON'T HAVE AN EXACT
SPLIT AS TO HOW MUCH IT'S GOING
TO GO TO URBAN VERSUS APPROVAL
HOWEVER BUT I CAN TELL YOU THAT
EVERY COUNTY IN THE STATE IS
GOING TO RECEIVE A SHARE THE
FUNDING. AND EVERY CONTINUE OF
CARE IN THE STATE'S GONNA
RECEIVE A SHARE OF THE FUNDING
AND ALSO ORDER STERN CITIES
UNIVERSITY THE SHARE OF THE
FUNDING SO I CAN TELL YOU THAT
EVERY ON EVERY LOCALITY IN THE
STATE BECAUSE- RULES GOING TO
GET A SHARE OF THIS MONEY OKAY
SO THAT IS A- THAT IS A DIRECT.
ALLOCATION TO. EACH CITY COUNTY
IN CONSUMER CARE IT DOESN'T
PASSED THROUGH ANYTHING- IT IS
IT'S ON A GRANT THAT THEY HAVE
TO APPLY. CORRECT FOR THE
HOMELESS HOUSING ASSISTANCE AND
PROGRAM- THE HELP MONIES THE
MONTH AND THE LOCAL HAVE TO
APPLY TO RECEIVE THE ONES-
THAT'LL THAT'LL GET BUT- I'M
HOMES CORNING FINANCING. ALSO A
PLAN FOR HOW THEY'RE GONNA
EXTEND THE MONIES AND HOW
THEY'RE GOING TO ACHIEVE
MEASURABLE METRICS FOR.
REDUCING THEIR- ALMOST MISSED
PROBLEMS AND THEN THEY WILL
RECEIVE THOSE MONEYS FROM HDFC
HOW MONSTER PLANS BEEN
APPROVED. OKAY AND THEN IN
TERMS OF METRICS HOW DO YOU
DEFINE SUCCESS. WITH THE USE OF
THESE RESOURCES. WHICH I WHICH
I BELIEVE IS NECESSARY. YES AN
ECONOMY IS REALLY BEDROCK THIS
PROPOSAL I THINK. AND WHAT'S
GOING TO HAPPEN IS YOU WILL
EACH LOCAL. APPLICANT POOLS-
SET IT WILL SET A GOAL SET
MEASURABLE GOALS THAT METAL
METRICS RATHER THAN ACHIEVE.
SUCCESS AND IN A WORK
COLLABORATIVE WITH THE HOUSING
COURT MEETING FINANCING COUNCIL
FOR TO ACHIEVING THE BULK OF
BILLS. AND THEN THEY WILL
RECEIVE FUNDING TO HELP. MEET
THOSE GOALS IN FUNDING FOR THE
FUTURE WOULD DEPEND UPON OUR
PROGRESS TOWARD ACHIEVING THOSE
GOALS. SO AGAIN ACCOUNTABILITY
AND MEASURABLE METRICS TOWARDS
RESOLVING ALMOST AS IF YOU ARE
A KEY TO THIS PROGRAM. SO I
WANT TO FOCUS ON THAT BECAUSE
THAT'S AN IMPORTANT POINT SO.
THE MEASURABLE GOALS SO WHAT
NUMBER DO THEY USE IS AT THE
POINT TIME COUNT IS IT A
COMBINATION. OF- DIFFERENT DAY.
IS ALONG WITH THE POINT TIME
COUNT- WHAT'S THE BASELINE AND
THEN AND THEN BECAUSE THAT BASS
LINES THAT ARE MEANT A WHOLE
LOT OF. OF WHAT. WE SEE AS
MEASURABLE SUCCESS OR FAILURE.
YES THE BASE PLANS GOING TO BE
THE TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN COULD
COUNT WHICH IS THE MOST
ACCURATE THAT WE HAVE AVAILABLE
RIGHT NOW BECAUSE TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY WASN'T. DONE UNIFORMLY
THROUGHOUT THE ENTIRE STATE AND
ALSO TWO THOUSAND TWENTY DID
NOT INCLUDE ACCOUNT OF THE-
UNSHELTERED HOMELESS SO WE'RE
USING TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN TED
WHICH VOTERS OF COLOR PICTURE
WE BELIEVE. OKAY SO THE TWENTY
NINETEEN PIC COUNT WILL BE THE
BASS LINE THAT WE'LL WILL JUDGE
THE SUCCESS OR FAILURE OF THIS
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT. TO MAKE
SURE I UNDERSTOOD YES SO IT'S
LOW THAT'S CORRECT AGAIN TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN WILL BE THE
BASE AND THEN EACH LOCAL
APPLICANT WILL DEVELOP A PLAN
TO- TO A TRIP THAT NUMBER SO TO
SPEAK AND REDUCE THE NUMBER OF.
HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS IN THE
COMMUNITY AND THEY WILL WORK
COLLABORATIVELY ON THAT PLAN
WITH THE HOMELESS CORDY
FINANCING COUNCIL AND- SO IT IS
NOT GONNA BE ABLE OF COURSE TO
SETTING THE VETERANS ON THEIR
OWN IT'S GOING TO BE THEY'RE
GOING TO BE WORKING WITH IT
CSE. SO IT'S YES YOU CAN INSURE
THOSE METRICS ARE REALISTIC AND
ACHIEVABLE AND SO YOU'RE GONNA
HAVE THAT THE STATE AND LOCAL
WORKING TOGETHER TO INSURE YOUR
SETTING ACHIEVABLE REALISTIC
GOALS OKAY AND THOSE AND THOSE
GOALS WILL BE POSTED SO WE'LL
KNOW. WHAT THOSE GOALS ARE SO
WE KNOW WHAT KERN COUNTY'S GOAL
AS WE KNOW WHAT LOS ANGELES
GOALS IS WE KNOW WHAT THANK.
ONE IS THAT IS THAT. KIND OF
HOW IT'S GONNA BE A GENTLEMAN
MEMBER. BOB HAILING A MEMBER
EACH- EACH. XCSE WILL POST
EACH- EACH APPLICANT'S PLAN
CONTROLS OUR WEBSITE OKAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- I TAUGHT A
CLASS FOR ONE THING I SENT OF
THE DISTRIBUTION IS BASED ON
PREVIOUS YEAR SO IT'S BASED ON
A PERCENT IT'S ABOUT THE
PERCENTAGE BASED ON THE
POPULATION. OF THE TWENTY
NINETEEN PECAN AND SO THAT'S
HOW IT GETS DISTRIBUTED TO THE
CBO SEES THE CITIES AS WELL AS
THE COUNTIES- ALSO. THE- THERE
IS THERE IS A CAP SO THAT NO
ONE ENTITY CAN GET MORE THAN
FORTY FIVE PERCENT. OKAY SAID
THIS SAID THAT THE ALLOCATION
OF FUNDS WILL BE A PERCENT IS
BASED ON POPULATION GROWTH- OF-
THE HOMELESS POPULATION- BUT
THAT HOMELESS POPULATION IS THE
TWENTY NINETEEN CORRECT TOTAL
POPULATION THAT'S OKAY. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR. UP YEAH IT TO
THE RESOURCES- BILL- WENT. ONE
FORTY EIGHT- WITH THE END I
GUESS THERE'S A AN INCREASE IN
THE IN THE FEE OF PER BARREL O
OIL- FROM SIXTY FIVE CENTS
EIGHTY FIVE CENTS- WHERE DID
THOSE PROCEEDS GO AND- WHAT
DOES THAT MEAN TO THE AVERAGE
CONSUMER- IS THERE CONCERN OF
THE- THE OF THE IMPACT ON THE
PRICE PER GALLON OF GASOLINE.
YEAH THANK YOU FOR THAT
QUESTION- I WILL TURN IT OVER
TO. OUR SPECIFIC TO MY
COLLEAGUES BUT I BELIEVE THE
INCREASE IS A PER BARREL FEE
FROM SIX POINT FIVE CENTS TO
EIGHT POINT 5% I'M SORRY THAT I
READ THAT WRONG SIX POINTFIVE
CENTS. TO EIGHT POINT FIVE
CENTS. YES DRIVE OVER THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- SO THE
FEE INCREASE IS INTENDED TO
ADDRESS A STRUCTURAL DEFICIT
AND THE BALLOT FUND. WHICH
SUPPORTS- DIFFERENT- CAN
REGULARS GOOD ACTIVITIES FOR
THE OFFICE OF OIL SPILL
PREVENTION AND RESPONSE- AND
SO. AS PART OF LAST YEAR.
PROVIDE A LOAN TO THE FUNDED
GIVEN THE STRUCTURAL DEFICIT.
BUT THIS- FEE INCREASE WOULD
ADDRESS THAT **** UP WITH IT
WHICH BASICALLY JUST MAINTAINS
THEIR THEIR CURRENT EXPENDITURE
LEVEL- WE DID DO HAVE ECONOMIC.
IMPACT REVIEW TO SEE WHAT
POTENTIAL IMPACT THAT WOULD
HAVE ON- THE CONSUMER AND SO
THE TWO PURPOSE AND INCREASE
AND FEDERAL WOULD RESULT IN
APPROXIMATELY 4% OF A PENNY. AT
THE GALLON AT THE PUMP. 4% OF
THE VALUE OKAY- I GUESS THE
QUESTION WOULD BE IF THERE'S A
STRUCTURAL DEFICIT AND THERE
ARE OTHER STRUCTURAL DEFICITS
IN A LOT OF ACCOUNTS THROUGHOUT
THE BUDGET WHY NOT WITH THE
SURPLUS- USE THE AT THE ADDED
RESOURCES THAT CAME TO THE
STATE PURSES OF A FEE INCREASE.
THIS IS A DEBATE FUND THAT YOU
KNOW PER STATUE. THAT THE
REVENUE SOURCE THAT FUND THESE
ACTIVITIES FOR- THE AUTHOR THE
WORLD PROFESSIONAL RESPONSE SO
WE THINK IT IS APPROPRIATE TO
CONTINUE FUNDING THE STATUTORY
MANDATED WORK OF THAT OFFICE-
WITH THEIR DESIGNATED- FUND FOR
EVERY. SO LET ME CHALLENGE YOU
THEIR LITTLE BIT THERE OTHER
FEE BASED FUNDS- I THINK- BUT A
VEHICLE FUND IS A FEE BASED
FUND BUT- BUT YOU'RE NOT
RAISING THOSE FEES. FOR THEIR
STRUCTURE WITH THEIR SON
SOLVENCY ISSUES. MR FONG THANK
YOU FOR THAT POINT I THINK IT
GENERALLY- BUT WHEN THERE ARE
ISSUES WITH PARTICULAR FUNDS WE
TRY TO WORK WITH THEM. IN
REGARDS TO WIN THEY MAY BECOME
INSOLVENT AND THIS IS ONE OF
THOSE FUNDS THAT- WE'D- YOU
KNOW IT'S TAKEN UP THIS YEAR-
YOU HAVE A BROADER. QUESTION I
THINK THAT IS SOMETHING THAT WE
LOOK AT EVERY YEAR AT VARIOUS
OF FINES. AND FEES. MIGHT BE
NECESSARY TO BE RAISED- AND
YOUR POINT ABOUT THE DMV IS
SOMETHING THAT YOU WE'VE LOOKED
INTO THAT THE STATUS OF THAT
FIND. ANNUALLY THE CIVICALLY
BECAUSE THAT IS- ONE THAT MANY
PEOPLE THINK IT TOO AND SO I
THINK YOUR QUESTION IS MY PRIDE
AND IT'S SOMETHING THAT WE LOOK
AT ACROSS ALL SPECIAL FUNDS.
OKAY I MEAN I GUESS THAT'S NOT
MY POINT IS THAT THIS IS A
CHOICE. EVEN BE MADE A POLICY
DECISION AND- YOU WANT TO
INCREASE THE STREET- EVEN
THOUGH I THINK THAT THERE'S
PROBABLY ANOTHER ALTERNATIVE.
AND BUT THE IMPACT IT WILL BE
TOO THERE WILL BE AN IMPACT OF
THE CONSUMER I KNOW I'M NOT
SURE THE 4% OF A PENNY IS
COMPLETELY ACCURATE. BUT- I
WILL SAY THAT. TO ROUTE RAISE A
FEE FROM SIX POINT FIVE CENTS A
POINT FIVE CENTS PER BARREL-
WILL HAVE AN IMPACT ON THE
PRICE OF GASOLINE IN THE PRICE
OF ENERGY IN GENERAL. AND I
THINK THAT WITH. THE THAT
NGUYEN FATHER SURPLUS I WANTED
TO FIND OUT THAT WE HAVE NOW.
IF IT IS AS IMMEDIATE AS YOU
SAY IT IS. I THINK THAT YOU
COULD PROBABLY BACK FILL IT
WITH WITH THE S. P. ADDED
SURPLUS- IN TERMS OF. IF YOU
LOOK INTO THE BRING THE BILL I
BELIEVE THERE'S- SEVERAL
EXEMPTIONS FROM THE
ADMINISTRATIVE PROCEDURES ACT-
FOR PROGRAMS FUNDED THROUGH THE
AIR RESOURCES BOARD-
EXEMPTIONS- THAT COVER-
ALTERNATIVES AG BURNING IN THE
SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY AND THE
SEVEN CENTER PROGRAMS. THERE
HAVE BEEN. A NUMBER OF AUDITS-
LED BY- OUR OUR FORMER A
TRANSPORTATION CHAIR- CONCERNED
ABOUT THE ACTIVITIES OF THEIR
RESOURCES BOARD- AND THESE
EXEMPTIONS PREVENT PUBLIC INPUT
AND PARTICIPATION SO. HOW DID.
HOW DID THESE EXEMPTIONS COME
INTO PLAY WHO WAS CONSULTED AND
WHAT'S THE JUSTIFICATION FOR
THEM. YES AGAIN SIR DO I GOT
WITH THE PART OF FINANCE AND SO
CURRENTLY THE DIFFERENCE THERE
ARE PROGRAMS THAT ARE PART OF
THE EXEMPTION THEY THEY ALREADY
DO HAVE B. A. P. EXEMPTION-
WHEN THEY'RE FUNDED OUT OF CAP
AND TRADE. AFTER THE THOSE KIND
OF CONTINUATION OF THAT BUT
GIVEN THAT WE FUNDED THE
PROGRAMS WITH A MIX OF CAP AND
TRADE AND GENERAL FUND. I WENT
TO CUENTA THEIR GENERAL FUND
AND THAT SAME EXEMPTION DOES
NOT EXTEND ABSOLUTE MERELY JUST
IT IS A REFLECTION OF. THE FUN
SORT OF CHANGE THAT WE WANT THE
PROGRAM TO HAVE THE SAME
EXEMPTION IT CURRENTLY HAS- AND
SO- IT REALLY JUST IS MORE OF A
TECHNICAL BASED OFF OF THE FUND
THAT- IS- FUNDING. THE PROGRAM
THIS YEAR. OKAY I WOULD SAY
THOUGH THAT IF YOU GONNA ON
ONCE. YOU ERR ON THE SIDE.
TOWARDTRANSPARENCY NOT AWAY
FROM IT. WOULDN'T YOU AGREE. OR
HAS THE OFFICE ADMINISTRATIVE
LAW HAVE THEY BEEN CONSULTED
WITH THIS DECISION. I THINK
WHAT I WOULD HIGHLIGHT IS
ESPECIALLY ON THE THEY ARE BE
PROGRAM THEY DO HAVE YOU KNOW-
PUBLIC PROCESS THE THROUGH THE
BOARD IS JUST NOT THAT SAME.
APA- PROCESS. BUT AGAIN JUST
GIVEN THAT THE PROGRAMS
CURRENTLY ALREADY DO HAVE. THE
áP EXEMPTION THEY'RE JUST
ALLOW THEM TO CONTINUE AND THEN
GET THE FUNDING OUT QUICKER
RATHER THAN HAVING TO RESTART
THE PROGRAM. I WHICH AGAIN
CURRENTLY ALREADY HAVE THE AB
EXACT OKAY. WELL I WOULD SAY AS
AS AS SOMEONE WHO SAT ON THE
COMMITTEE THAT REVIEWED THE
AUDIT. INCLUSIONS I THINK THAT
THAT THERE IS SEVERE CHALLENGES
WITH IN CAR. WHEN IT COMES TO-
THEIR ABILITY OR CAPACITY TO
OVERSEE THESE PROJECTS AND I
THINK MORE TRANSPARENCY IS
PROBABLY NECESSARY- TO MAKE
SURE THAT THESE FUNDS ARE BEING
USED PROPERLY- AND I AM
CONCERNED THAT. EXPANDING THESE
EXEMPTIONS ACTUALLY MOVES US IN
THE WRONG DIRECTION- INTIMATE
AND THAT MAY BE SOMETHING THAT-
WE NEED TO HAVE A BROADER
COMMITTEE- CONVERSATION ABOUT-
BUT THAT THINGS ITS IT'S-
SOMETHING THAT WE HAVE TO BE
COGNIZANT OF- AND I'M- I'M
DEEPLY CONCERNED ABOUT THAT-
JUMPING TO YOU- TO BROADBAND-
WHY IS THE SEQUEL EXEMPTION
LIMITED TO THE MIDDLE MILE WHY
NOT APPLY IT TO THE MIDDLE MILE
AND LAST MILE. HI MISTER BY
WILL TURN THAT QUESTION OVER TO
MY COLLEAGUE. NUMBER ONE- TO
PARTLY FINANCE. WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT THE SEQUENCE ACTIONS
IMPORTANT TO REMEMBER THAT IT'S
REALLY MORE OF A STREAMLINING
RIGHT AND SO- YOU CAN IMAGINE
THAT- ON WHAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT USING. LAND ALONG STATE
HIGHWAYS SO THERE'S ALREADY IN
YOUR ROBUST ENVIRONMENTAL
PROCESS THAT HAS BEEN FOLLOWED-
TO PUT THE ROAD THERE IN THE
FIRST PLACE IS A LOT OF
INFORMATION WHERE BEHALF SO
REALLY. IT'S NOT- AND BECOME A
CONDUIT AND ALREADY EXEMPTION-
BUT IT'S REALLY JUST TRYING TO
CAPITALIZE ON. THE WORK THAT
THE CALTRANS IS ALREADY DONE-
AND- IT IS TO SPEED THE PROJECT
ALONG- IT WOULD BE MUCH MORE
EXPENSIVE AND WE CAN'T REALLY
SPEAK TO WEAR IN TERMS OF THE
LAST MILE WHERE THAT WOULD GO-
THEN THAT'S THAT'S REALLY UP TO
THE PROVIDERS TO KIND OF
CONTROL THAT SO. WE JUST MADE
IT TO THE MIDDLE MILE OKAY WELL
LET ME USE YOUR LANGUAGE THEN
SO LET'S SAY IT'S EQUESTRIAN
RIDING RIGHT I WOULD SAY THAT
IF WE'RE GOING TO MAKE OUR
DOLLAR GO FURTHER. IT WOULD
MAKE SENSE TO APPLY IT TO THE
MIDDLE MILE AND LAST MILE
WOULDN'T YOU AGREE. TO THE
EXTENT THAT. I THINK WE CAN
ONLY SPEAK TO THE- TO THE
SEQUEL PROCESSES THAT CALTRANS
ALREADY FOLLOW THE BODY FOUND
ON THE STATE HIGHWAY SYSTEM-
AND WE- THERE'S NOT WE DON'T
HAVE THAT SAME LEVEL OF
INFORMATION FOR. WHAT'S THE I
WOULD SECTOR WOULD BE DOING IN
TERMS OF PROVIDERS YEAH WE'RE
GONNA GO TO THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE AS WELL- ANSWER
MISTER CHAIR THIS SECTION OF
THE ASSEMBLY BUDGET COMMITTEE
ON THIS PARTICULAR- SEQUEL
EXEMPTION- IT PLUS THE RIGHT OF
WAYS AND IT CAN ACTUALLY IS A
ELIGIBLE FOR THE MIDDLE MILE OR
FOR NONPROFIT OR EVEN A FOR
PROFIT PROVIDERS LONG AS IT'S
ALONG THE RIGHT AWAY TO THE
EXEMPTIONS REALLY ABOUT WHERE
THE WHERE THE LINE IS LAID NOT
WHETHER IT'S MIDDLE MILE THE
LAST MILE IT'S JUST WHETHER
YOU'RE USING THIS RIGHT AWAY
FOR THAT OKAY SO ANY. SO ANY.
ANY PROJECT THAT IS ON EXISTING
RIGHT AWAY IT WOULD BE ELIGIBLE
FOR THIS. THE LIMITED- GROUP OF
THE GIFT RIGHT OF WAYS BUT YES
IF IT IF IT IS THE RIGHT AWAY
IT DOESN'T MATTER IF IT MENTAL
MINE A LOT OF MILEAGE HAVE TO
BE USED OKAY. I SEE I SEE YOUR
POINT I THINK FOR THOSE OF US
IN IT WHO HAVE WHO HAVE
EXPERIENCED A SEQUEL- FOR A LOT
OF PROJECTS WHETHER IT'S ROADS
OR ANYTHING ELSE IT TENDS TO BE
CUMBERSOME IT TENDS TO BE VERY
LINK THEY TEND TO BE LOOKS POOR
EXPENSIVE SO. IF WE CAN RUN
THAT OUT I THINK THAT THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE NEED TO- TOOK
TO LOOK AT- AS WELL- I GUESS
IT'S BACK TO THEBOMBING OF
FINANCE JUMPING TO JUST METRICS
AGAIN- A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF
MONEY IS BEING. INVESTED I WANT
TO SAY IT'S ABOUT FOUR POINT
FIVE BILLION DOLLARS- SO HOW DO
YOU DEFINE SUCCESS IS IT THE
AMOUNT OF CONNECTIONS IT'S IS
THAT THE AMOUNT OF COMMUNITIES
THAT ARE BEING GET CONNECTED TO
BROADBAND- APPLE. HOW DO WE
KNOW WHAT. WHAT IS IN EUROPEAN.
OVER THE MISSISSIPPI WHAT IS
SUCCESS. WE HAVE. THE INITIAL
MEASURE THAT WE HAD USED FOR OR
THE- SIX HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE
THOUSAND A MONTH- COUNCILS OF
THE STATE- AND THOSE ARE
HOUSEHOLDS BUT PHYSICALLY DON'T
HAVE. ACCESS TO BROADBAND
SERVICE I'M SO CERTAINLY THE
NUMBER OF HOUSEHOLDS SERVED-
COME INTO PLAY COMMUNITY
SERVICE. COME INTO PLAY- THERE
ARE YOU KNOW LIKE A NUMBER FOR
THE COMMUNITIES IN THE STATE
THAT. THIS MONTH SAYS DON'T
HAVE ACCESS AND SO. SHOULD BE
REACHING OUT AND HAVING BROKER
BE ABLE TO GET TO ALL OF THE
COMMUNITIES. REGARDLESS OF
WHERE THEY ARE WOULD BE ANOTHER
MEASURE. SO THE SIX SEVEN SEVEN
FIVE THOUSAND UNSERVED THAT'S
THE OTAL AMOUNT OF UNSERVED-
HOUSEHOLDS IN CALIFORNIA. THE
AND- THAT YOU HAVE THAT YOUR
ACCOUNT. THAT IS WHAT. THE
INDUSTRY HAS REPORTED TO THE
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION. IN
TERMS OF WHERE. THEY ARE UNABLE
TO PROVIDE SERVICE. SO AND
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE WILL
CONTINUE TO- THAT THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION WILL
CONTINUE TO REVISIT MARC ON.
OKAY WELL I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT AS THE LEGISLATURE TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT THAT NUMBER IS.
SO IF THE NUMBER IS SIX ARE
SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND UNSERVED.
HOUSEHOLDS THE NEXT YEAR WHEN
WE HAVE THIS DISCUSSION OF HOW
THE MONEY IS BEING USED. I
WOULD PRESUME THAT WE WOULD
HAVE LESS OR WHATEVER THAT
NUMBER IS SO THAT WE CAN
ACTUALLY MEASURE. SUCCESS WHO
IS THAT IS THAT BUILT INTO THE-
INTO THE INTO THE PROJECT OR
INTO THE FUNDING. HI MR YES IT
IS YES THERE ARE THERE'S A
REPORTING MEASURES IN THE BILL
THAT ARE ACTUALLY TO THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE SO THAT WE CAN HAVE
THOSE CONVERSATIONS GOING
PERFECT. AND THAT'S AND THAT'S
GOING TO BE ANNUALLY WORKS
EVERY MARCH EVERY MARCH YES.
PERFECT AND THEN THIS IS. IT'S
OVERSEEN BY DEPUTY WITHIN
DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY IS
THAT CORRECT. YES OKAY AND
DEPARTMENT TECHNOLOGY HAS THE
CAPABILITY OF. OF OVERSEEING
THIS SUBSTANTIAL AMOUNT OF WORK.
YES OF THE- THE- SURE THE BILL
PROVIDES FOR THE CONTRACT WITH
A THIRD PARTY ADMINISTRATOR AND
SO- THE TECHNOLOGY THAT C. T.
DOES HAVE A CERTAIN LEVEL OF
EXPERTISE YOU KNOW. IT DIDN'T
WORK IN UNDERSTANDING THAT. THE
BROADBAND INDUSTRY INDUSTRY
BUT- THIS IS VERY MUCH INTENDED
TO DEPEND ON. THE THIRD PARTY
ADMINISTRATOR THAT THEY WOULD
CONTRACT WITH THAT WOULD- THAT
UNDERPIN HAS AS A VERY THOROUGH
AND IS INVOLVED IN THAT THEIR
KNOWLEDGE EVIDENCE INVOLVED IN
THE BROADBAND INDUSTRY. I'M SO
I'M GONNA BE VERY DEPENDENT ON
THEM OKAY WELL. I WILL BE ULLY
TRANSPARENT WITH YOU THAT I
CONCERNS ABOUT THE DEVICE
TECHNOLOGY ARE PRETTY WELL
FOUNDED IF YOU LOOK AT FISCALE.
YOU LOOK AT THE I. T. PROGRAMS
IN THE DMV YOU LOOK AT E. D. D.
YOU LOOK AT CALVARY'S YOU EVEN
LOOK AT THE MOST RECENTLY ARE
ARE IN. THE STATE'S INABILITY
TO DISTRIBUTE RENTAL
ASSISTANCE. I THINK THAT
THERE'S SIGNIFICANT CONCERNS OF
THE CAPACITY AND SO WE'RE GOING
TO INVEST IN I THINK RIGHTFULLY
SO- FUNDING FOR BROADBAND AND
CONNECTING- AND UNDERSERVED OR
UNSERVED HOUSEHOLDS WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE MONEY GOES
AS FAR AS POSSIBLE. AND AS
EFFECTIVE AS POSSIBLE- I THINK
THAT CONCLUDES MY QUESTIONS
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU MR VICE TO REMEMBER
MISS FRIEDMAN. THANK YOU-
MISTER CHAIR- FIRST I WANT TO-
REALLY THANK YOU AND
ACKNOWLEDGE THE WORK THAT YOU
AND YOUR STAFF HAVE BEEN DOING
FOR MANY MONTHS NOW ON THIS
BUDGET I KNOW THAT YOU'VE BEEN
WORKING NIGHT AND DAY OVER
WEEKENDS. TRYING TO DEAL WITH
ALL THE STAKEHOLDERS ACROSS THE
STATE DEALING WITH PRETTY MUCH
EVERY AREA- THAT WE FUNDS SO I
WANTED JUST PERSONALLY THANK
YOU FOR ALL OF THAT INCREDIBLE
WORK. I DO WANT TO RAISE A
CONCERN ABOUT- AB ONE FORTY IN
TERMS OF THE SPENDING CAP- IT
IT DOESN'T MAKE SENSE TO ME TO
SAY. THAT WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE SEND MONEY TO THE
PLACES WHERE WE'RE EXPERIENCING
THE MOST HOMELESSNESS AND THEN
AT THE SAME TIME SAY AND WAS
THAT PLACE HAPPENS TO BE LOS
ANGELES. IT DOESN'T COST LESS
PER PERSON TO SERVICE A PERSON
ON THE STREETS IN LOS ANGELES
AS IT DOES IN ANOTHER COUNTY OR
ANOTHER CITY. IF LOS ANGELES
CITY HAS THE HIGHEST POPULATION
OF HOMELESS THEY SHOULD
CERTAINLY HAVE THE SAME AMOUNT
PER CAPITA AS ANY OTHER AREA OF
THE STATE BECAUSE THIS IS THE
EPICENTER OF OUR HOMELESS
EPIDEMIC. AND SO I BELIEVE THAT
WE SHOULD BE SPENT AN EQUAL
AMOUNT PER CAPITA ACROSS THE
STATE AND NOT HAVE AN ARBITRARY
CAP THAT SIPHONS MONEY AWAY
FROM LOS ANGELES TO SEND IT TO
OTHER AREAS WHERE THEY WILL
RECEIVE MORE PER CAPITA- THAT
DOESN'T MAKE SENSE TO ME UNLESS
I'M MISUNDERSTANDING THIS IT
SEEMS TO ME THAT. WE SHOULD BE
SENDING MORE FUNDING INTO THE
AREAS WHERE WE HAVE THE WORST
HOMELESS PROBLEM MORE HOMELESS
PEOPLE ARE CONGREGATING- WHERE.
WE SEE THE HUGE IMPACTS OF
HOMELESS PEOPLE- YOU KNOW WE
REALLY NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE ADDRESS THAT AND I EIGHT I
DON'T UNDERSTAND ANY I CAN'T
COME UP WITH ANY POLICY REASON
WHY YOU'D WANT TO SPEND LESS
PER CAPITA IN THE EPICENTER OF
OUR HOMELESSNESS CRISIS. WOULD
YOU LIKE TO BE. A FAMILY MEMBER
FRIEDMAN I'M NOT SURE IF
THERE'S- ABOUT THE QUESTION
THAT I WOULD JUST ADD. THAT IN
THE PAST WHEN WE HAVE- BUT
CAPTAIN FOR HAP OR HOMELESSNESS
SPENDING- IN REGARDS TO A LATE
HUSBAND. WITH THAT. THE END
TIMES THAT SOME OF THOSE
DOLLARS HAVE- CAN ACTUALLY BE A
BENEFIT. BENEFITS THEY'RE A
BENEFIT THAT AREA DEGREE DEGREE
BECAUSE OF THE SCALE- AND THE
AMOUNT OF DOLLARS THAT ARE THAT
ARE GOING TO THAT AREA SO THAT
THEY CAN MAXIMIZE OUR TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THAT BUT I WILL
TURN IT OVER TO CHRIS HOPE TO
SEE IF THERE'S ANYTHING ELSE
THAT. WE ARE I WANNA MAKE SURE
I UNDERSTAND YOUR POINT IS YOUR
POINT THAT IT SOMEHOW BENEFITS
LOS ANGELES MORE TO RECEIVE
LESS FUNDING. NO NO AT.
APOLOGIZE FOR THAT I THINK THAT
WOULD THERE WAS THERE IS A
SENSE THAT BECAUSE THEY ARE SO
LARGE. THAT THEY HAVE- THAT
THEY CAN BENEFIT FROM SCALE IN
TERMS OF BEING ABLE TO MOVE
BACKWARDS. AND OR OR- I WOULD
PROVIDE THE SERVICES AND
PROGRAMS AT AT AT AT AT AT
BURKE FOR CHEAPER ESSENTIALLY
WELL I WILL TELL YOU THAT THAT
IS CERTAINLY NOT THEIR
FEELINGS. I LOS ANGELES DOES
NOT FEEL LIKE THEY'RE GOING TO
BENEFIT ENOUGH FROM SCALE THAT
THEY'RE WILLING THAT THEY THINK
THAT THEY SHOULD RECEIVE LESS
MONEY PER CAPITA THAN OTHER
PARTS OF THE STATE. I WOULD SAY
THAT THEY HAVE A LOT OF REASONS
WHY MAYBE IT'S HARDER TO
SERVICE. THE HOMELESS
POPULATION IN LOS ANGELES- NOT
LESS DIFFICULT AND LOS ANGELES
IS EXTREMELY CONCERNED ABOUT
THE REDUCTION IN FUNDING- THEY
ARE. FACING A HUGE ALMOST
INSURMOUNTABLE. CRISIS WITH
HOMELESSNESS- YEAH I MEAN I
KNOW THAT THERE IS ISSUES IN
OTHER PARTS OF THE STATE BUT
I'M NOT FOR THAT THEY WERE
APPROACHING AND MOST OF OUR
AREAS. THE REAL SENSE OF ALMOST
JUST HOPELESSNESS WHEN IT COMES
TO THE GROWING HOMELESSNESS
HOMELESS POPULATION. IN LOS
ANGELES AND I DON'T BELIEVE
THAT THIS IS THE TIME TO SITE
TO TAKE MONEY OUT OF THAT
SYSTEM AND SEND IT OTHER PLACES
I JUST I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY.
SOMEHOW IT SHOULD COST LESS
MONEY TO SERVICE HOMELESS
PEOPLE IN LOS ANGELES. AND
APOLOGIZE FOR NOT BEING FAIR I
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO ADD THAT
THERE ARE A LOT OF OTHER
BUCKETS OF FUNDS IN THIS-
BUDGET NOT JUST IS THE HELP OF
FUNDING- THAT- PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL SERVICES MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES AS WELL AS
OTHER SERVICES HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS- BUT I DO WANT TO
TURN IT OVER CHRIS COOK FOR.
SOME SPECIFICS. YES CHRIS COOK
WITH DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- AS
MISLI JUST INDICATED THERE ARE
SEVERAL OTHER FUNDING SOURCES
IN THE BUDGET. THAT DEFINITELY
L. A. COUNTY- CITY CAN TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF AND I WOULD JUST
LIKE THE CARE- CLARIFY. THAT
THE CURRENT METHODOLOGY ONLY
REALLY IMPACTS- AT LAKE CITY L.
A. R. THE CEO SEES IN THE AREA
AND THE COUNTIES ARE NOT- HIT
THAT THEY DON'T THEY WILL NOT
HIT THAT CAP- AND I WILL ALSO
NOTE THAT I DON'T KNOW IF I
WOULD NECESSARILY SAY IF A
REDUCTION FUNDING. THIS YEAR'S
BUDGET PROVIDES A SUBSTANTIAL
AMOUNT OF HOMELESS FLEXIBLE
EIGHT- THE LARGEST THAT THE
STATE HAS EVER MADE IN THIS
AREA WHICH IS ALMOST DOUBLE THE
HIGHEST THAT WHAT IT'S RECEIVED
IN THE PAST. AND I WOULD AND I
WOULD SAY THAT A LAKE CITY
SPECIFICALLY IS GETTING EIGHTY
ONE MILLION DOLLARS MORE THAN
THEY HAD RECEIVED IN THE PRIOR
YEAR- WHICH IS A FIVE STAR AND
YET NOT A REDUCTION FUNDING
CERTAINLY COMPARED TO PREVIOUS
YEARS. BUT THE REDUCTION OF PER
CAPITA FUNDING COMPARED TO
OTHER REGIONS SO ARE YOU
TELLING ME THAT THERE'S OTHER
POTS OF MONEY THAT LOS ANGELES
CITY CAN ACCESS AND OTHER
CITIES CAN'T ACCESS. OR AND ALL
THESE ARE THESE CARE ACT AS
MONEY OR MENTAL HEALTH SO I'M
GONNA ANSWER THE QUESTION ON
THE PREVIOUS QUESTION WHICH IS.
STILL LA CITY FOR THE NEXT YEAR
IS GETTING A HUNDRED AND FORTY
THREE. MILLION DOLLARS BY FAR
THE LARGEST AMOUNT OF ANY CITY-
IN THE ENTIRE STATE BECAUSE OF
THE POPULATION. WHAT THEY ARE
MISSING OUT ON THIS THIRTEEN
MILLION SO. THEIR NEXT ELECTION
IS FIFTY SIX MILLION- WHICH I
WOULD HAVE AN ISOLATION IS
INCORRECT. THE THEIR
CALCULATION IS THAT IT'S A
REDUCTION IN THAT NOT WITHOUT
IT NOT A REDUCTION SORRY
WITHOUT THE CAP. URATE
REDUCTION IS ABSOLUTELY THE
WRONG WE'RE GOING TO BE USING
BECAUSE IT'S BASED ON AND OUR
BUDGET CONSULTANT CAN WALK
THROUGH THE CALCULATION BUT
THEIR CALCULATION IS INCORRECT
OKAY GENEVIEVE MORALE YEAH
THEIR CALCULATION IS NINETY SIX
MILLION AND MISLEADING THE-
MANAGER OF THE COMMITTEE. SORRY
SO WHAT I'M GONNA GO TO ANSWER
YOUR QUESTION THANKS WITH YOUR
QUESTIONS AND THEN YOU CAN COME
BACK TO HER HOUSE FOR THE
QUESTIONS IN THE COMMENTS. HI
JENNIFER MORALES WITH THE
BUDGET COMMITTEE. AT GENERAL
ASSEMBLY BUDGET COMMITTEE I
MISS FRIEDMAN I THINK WHERE THE
CONFUSION COMES IN IS IN THE
BILL WHAT WE DID IS WE PROVIDED
A- UP. THE TOTAL IS ONE BILLION
DOLLARS BUT WHAT DID IS WE
PULLED OUT A BONUS POT SO THAT
STARTS THE TOTAL AMOUNT OF THE
POT OF FUNDING AT EIGHT HUNDRED
MILLION AND I BELIEVE THE
FUNDING THAT THE CITY OF ALLEY.
PROVIDED FOR YOU WITH THAT ONE
BILLION VERSUS EIGHT HUNDRED
MILLION AT IN CURRENTLY IN THE
BILL SO WHEN YOU LOOK AT THAT
THE NUMBERS THERE THE DELTA
BETWEEN THE TWO IS FIFTY AROUND
FIFTY ONE MILLION DOLLARS THAT
THEY'RE SAYING THEY'RE LOSING
BUT THAT'S BASED ON UP BILLION
DOLLAR POT. AND THE WAY THE
BILL READS IT'S BASED OFF OF AN
EIGHT HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR
CAUGHT AND SO WHAT THE
DIFFERENCE IS THIRTEEN MILLION
VERSUS FIFTY ONE MILLION SO I
THINK THEY JUST READ THE BILL
WHEN THEY SEND OUT THEIR THEIR
LETTER TODAY. OKAY I WASN'T
TRYING TO REPAIRS WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT I GOT OUT WITH THEIR
CONCERN WAS THAT THEY FELT THAT
IT WAS A FIFTY SIX MILLION
DOLLAR DELTA. SO THERE IS SO IN
OTHER WORDS WHAT YOU'RE SAYING
IS THAT THERE THE INITIAL THAT
THE SOME THEIR THEIR
OVERSTAFFED OVERSTATING WHAT
THE SOME WOULD BE SO THEY'VE
DONE THE CALCULATION AND SO
YOU'RE SAYING WHAT WHAT THE
DIFFERENCE WOULD. BE IS
FOURTEEN. THIRTEEN YEAH. YES
BUT IS THIRTEEN MILLION WE THIS
EIGHTEEN FOR BONUS POT SO
THAT'S STARTS OUT WHAT ALLEN
DAHLE ARE AT EIGHT HUNDRED
MILLION SO THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN THAT IS WHERE THEY GET
THEIR BIGGER NUMBER AND IF
THERE'S I HAVE A DIFFERENCE OF
FIFTY ONE MILLION AND THEY HAVE
A DIFFERENCE OF FIFTY SIX
MILLION BECAUSE THEY DIDN'T
TAKE OUT THE ADMIN SO- IF YOU
BASE IT OFF OF THE NUMBERS IN
THE BILL THAT THE DIFFERENCE
THAT ALLEY IS MISSING IS
THIRTEEN MILLION AND IF YOU
BASE IT OFF ELLIE'S LETTER THE
DIFFERENCE EMPTINESS FIFTY SIX
MILLION. SO I'M HAPPY TO SHARE
I HAVE A COUPLE CHARTS AND
HAPPY TO SHARE THEM WITH YOUR
OFFICE TO PROVIDE MORE CLARITY
THAT WOULD BE HELPFUL AND IT
WOULD BE NICE IF I CAN GET A
RESPONSE FROM LOS ANGELES BASED
ON THAT- SO THAT WE ALL
UNDERSTAND THAT WE ALL HAVE THE
SAME IDEA OF WHAT THE
DIFFERENCES BECAUSE THAT IS A
SIGNIFICANT DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
THIRTEEN MILLION AND FIFTY SIX
MILLION. I STILL DON'T
UNDERSTAND THE POLICY REASON
WHY YOU WOULD GIVE PER CAPITA
THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES WHICH
IS THE EPICENTER OF A HOMELESS
CRISIS LESS FUNDING PER CAPITA
THAN YOU WOULD GIVE OTHER PARTS
OF THE STATE IT'S STILL THAT
JUST DOESN'T MAKE ANY POLICIES
AS ME BUT ALL I WILL LEAVE IT
THERE AND THAT'S MY CONCERN
MISS MISS MORALES CAN YOU WALK
THROUGH THE FUNDING AMOUNTS FOR
THE OTHER CITIES THE OTHER OF-
FOURTEEN CITIES. AT THE OTHER.
THE R. THESE. THE OTHER LIFESON.
YEAH IN ORDER. OKAY HOLD ON ONE
SECOND. ASSEMBLY MEMBER THING I
HAVE THOSE AS WELL IF IT'S
HELPFUL FEELS PLEASE READ OFFER
WELL THANK YOU. THIS CONGRESS
CUT FROM DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
ARE SO AND- ANAHEIM WOULD
RECEIVE- TEN POINT THREE
MILLION BAKERSFIELD THREE POINT
NINE R. FOUR MILLION- FRESNO
SEVEN POINT FIVE. LONG BEACH
FIVE POINT SEVEN MILLION LOS
ANGELES. A HUNDRED AND FORTY
THREE POINT SIX MILLION OAKLAND
TWENTY FOUR POINT ONE MILLION.
RIVERSIDE EIGHT POINT FOUR
SACRAMENTO SIXTEEN POINT SEVEN
SAN DIEGO TWENTY SEVEN POINT
THREE. SAN FRANCISCO TWENTY
FOUR POINT ONE SAN JOSE TWENTY
NINE POINT TWO. SANTA ANA TEN
POINT THREE MILLION AND STOP
AND SEVEN POINT NINE OR EIGHT
MILLION. THANK YOU THINK MY
ONLY COMMENT IS I THINK BASED
ON THAT LISTING OF THE CITIES.
YOU CAN SEE AND HEAR FAR AWAY
THAT LA RECEIVES HE- LINE SHARE
OF THE FUNDING WHICH I THINK IS
APPROPRIATE GIVEN THE
POPULATION AND I THINK. ARMED
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE NUMBERS I
THINK IT'S A VERY APPROPRIATE
FUNDING LEVEL SO. THANK YOU
OTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS FROM
THE COMMITTEE MISSED FRAZIER-
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. JUST
WANT TO GO BACK TO THE- THE
MENTAL HEALTH OF THE BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH ASPECT OF WHEN- VISSCHER
FONG AND TALKED ABOUT THE OF
COUNTIES IN THE DEPARTMENT OF
STATE HOSPITALS I KNOW I
ADDRESSES CONCERNS. OF
PREVIOUSLY IN IN THE HEARINGS.
AND I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE WHEN
WE TALK ABOUT. ADDITIONAL
CAPACITY. WE'RE TALKING ABOUT.
STARTING FROM SCRATCH BASICALLY
AND BEING ABLE TO PROVIDE THIS
THIS- CAPACITY FOR THESE FOR
THESE PATIENTS ARE GOING TO BE
ESSENTIALLY TURNED OVER TO THE
COUNTY- AND I THINK SOLANO
COUNTY IT'S LIKE TWENTY HUNDRED
TWENTY EIGHT HUNDRED PEOPLE-
THAT ARE NOW BEING. CONTRACTED
THROUGH KAISER. AND LOOK I
THINK IT'S EIGHT THOUSAND PLUS
IN SACRAMENTO COUNTY I BELIEVE
IT WAS OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
AND SO WHEN WE TALK ABOUT YOU
KNOW PHASE IN AND AVAILABILITY
AND BEING ABLE TO ACCOMMODATE
IT AND MAKING SURE THAT THE
INDIVIDUALS ARE BEING CARED
FOR. FIRST AND FOREMOST- AND
THEN ADEQUATE FUNDING IS THEN
PROVIDED FROM THE DEPARTMENTS
AT HOSPITALS TO THE COUNTIES
CAPACITY I ONCE I JUST WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT TRANSITION. IS
STREAMLINED AND SMOOTH AS
POSSIBLE NOT TO INTERRUPT THE
BASIC CARE FOR THESE
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE MORE
EXTREME- MENTAL FRAGILE BY
MENTALLY FRAGILE I WOULD SAY
AND SO- THAT WAS THAT WAS THE
FIRST AND FOREMOST ON MIKE HOW
MAY YOU KNOW FOUGHT PROCESS THE
OTHER ONE WENT IN AND I REALLY
DO APPRECIATE THE COME THE
COMPONENT OF WORKING WITH
SCHOOLS. IN THE MENTAL HEALTH
AND BEHAVIORAL A CAPACITY
BECAUSE YOU LOOK AT ALL THE
SCHOOLS THAT I'VE GONE TO MY
DISTRICT THEY HAVE IT IN THEIR
EL CAP. BUT THEY DON'T THEY
DON'T ACCOMMODATE. AND SO THIS
GOING OUT AND BEING
ACCOMPLISHED IS HUGE FOR-
REDUCTION SUICIDES AND IN SO
MANY DIFFERENT AREAS WHERE WE A
LOT OF US AND WE'RE NOT GOING
TO DATE ANYBODY BUT WE HAVE A
GUIDANCE COUNSELOR THAT WE
WOULD GO TO. THAT WE COULD TALK
TO. I DON'T HAVE THAT NOW- THEY
DON'T HAVE THAT CAPACITY SO.
I'M JUST ALSO ASKING BECAUSE IN
THIS MENTAL HEALTH ROLE- WE'VE
SEEN THE DUAL DIAGNOSIS WITH
THE ID DEEP POPULATION WERE
WITH HAVE A- MAYBE A SEVERE
AUTISM BUT THEY ALSO HAVE-
MAYBE ANOTHER A MENTAL- OF.
CHALLENGE AND WANT TO MAKE SURE
IN THIS. IT'S BECAUSE SO MANY
THINGS ARE SILOS. YOU KNOW WHEN
YOU LOOK AT DDS AND- REGIONAL
CENTERS AND THE SOME OF THEDIFFERENT THINGS WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THIS MENTAL HEALTH
MONEY. ACCOMMODATES THAT ROLE
ALSO IN WITH THE ID POPULATION
CHRISTIAN I KNOW YOU'VE BEEN
PRETTY WELL. CAN YOU TELL ME-
IF IT'S SILENT AND IT HAS TO GO
THROUGH DDS OR REGIONAL CENTER
FOR THE FOR THE I. D. D.
POPULATION OR OR CAN IT BE
THROUGH THIS POSSIBILITY
THROUGH SPECIAL EDUCATION.
THROUGH THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
BUT IT'S FRAZIER I'M SORRY I
TOP MY HEAD I DON'T KNOW I
DON'T KNOW IF THAT COULD WORK
BECAUSE WHEN THINGS GO THROUGH
THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS THEY'RE
USUALLY POP AND EAT. AND IF I
GO THROUGH THE TEDIOUS IT ISN'T
SO THAT THAT HAS ALWAYS BEEN A
CHALLENGE AND I THINK THERE IS
WAYS THAT THINGS CAN WORK OUT
BETWEEN AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
WHERE. REGIONAL CENTERS CAN
CONTRACT WITH SCHOOL DISTRICTS
AND VICE VERSA BUT I. THINK AT
THE STATE LEVEL THE CHALLENGE
WE HAVE IS THAT YOU KNOW IF
YOU'RE TRYING TO GO DIRECTLY TO
SCHOOL TO ENABLE YEA. THAT'S
SHOWING A NINETY EIGHT USE- AS
OPPOSED TO NINE NINETY EIGHT
GENERAL FUND SO THAT THAT THAT
MAKES WILL COMPLICATED SO- BUT
I DEFERRED TO. EITHER FINANCE
OR- MY TEAM ON ON WEBEX AND
THEY HAVE MORE DETAILS ON THAT
OKAY. HEY JUST IF WE CAN WORK
OFFLINE ON THAT MISTER CHAIR
JUST TO MAKE SURE BECAUSE I
THINK BECAUSE THINGS ARE SO
SILOS THE THERE IS. A GROUP OF
WHAT WE CALL TRAINERS THAT MAY
BE CAUGHT UP IN THE- IN THE
DIFFERENT CATEGORIES AND SO I'M
JUST I'M JUST. A LITTLE BIT
CONCERNED ABOUT THAT AND THANK
YOU. I ANDREW MARC. WITH A BY
COMMITTEE COME. MAYBE THE CALL
HI ENTER ENTER MARGOLIS- WITH
THAT BUDGET COMMITTEE- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FRAZIER I THINK I'M PART
OF THE CONFUSION HERE IS- WHAT
THE VARIOUS DIFFERENT PROPOSALS
ARE THERE A LOT OF DIFFERENT
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH RELATED
PROPOSALS IN THIS IN THIS
BUDGET- ONE OF WHAT THE FIRST
ONE THAT YOU MENTIONED- HAS TO
DO THIS IS PART OF KATHLEEN-
WITH THE KAISER- CARVED OUT OF
SPECIALTY MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES FOR SOLANO AND
SACRAMENTO COUNTIES. AND THAT-
AND THAT CARVE OUT IS THE
ENDING IS CARD OF- COUNTY BUT
IT WAS DELAYED- AS YOU I THINK
MENTIONED TO BE PHASED IN- THAT
WITH THE REST OF THE THAT SO
IT'S SO IT'S DELAYED UNTIL THE
OTHER AT BEAVER HEALTH REFORMS
THAT ARE PART OF COUNTY BAR IN
PLACE- SO THAT IT CAN BE A
SMOOTHER TRANSITION AND
CONTINUITY CARE- PROVISIONS CAN
BE IN PLACE. SO THAT'S THAT
PART OF IT- IN TURN OF THE AYE
I AM T. I THERE'S ALSO SOME
KIND. AROUND THE FACT THAT THE
BUDGET INCLUDED PROPOSALS TO
SHIFT B. B. I. S. T. POPULATION
TO COUNTIES AND THEN A SECOND
PROPOSAL TO SHIFT THE LPS
COPULATIONS COUNTY. NEITHER OF
THOSE PROPOSALS ARE MOVING
FORWARD IN THIS BUDGET- BECAUSE
OF THE CONCERNS OF COUNTIES AND
FOR OTHER REASONS- AND INSTEAD
IS THE BEST THING FUNDS FOR.
THE DEVELOPMENT OF CAPACITY AT
THE COUNTY LEVEL IN ORDER TO
START SHIFTING SOME POPULATIONS
THAT ARE APPROPRIATE TO THE
COUNTIES IN ORDER TO CREATE
MORE CAPACITY IN THE STATE
HOSPITAL TO TREAT THE AYE IF HE
POPULATION- AND THEN FINALLY IN
TERMS. OF THE SCHOOL SERVICES
THE GOVERNOR'S CHIU AND YOUTH
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH INITIATIVE-
IT IT. IT I WOULD SAY PRIMARY
PURPOSE IS TO CREATE A SYSTEM
THAT IS. THAT SERVES ALL KIDS
REGARDLESS OF PAYOR SOURCE
REGARDLESS OF. THAT YOU KNOW
CONDITION MEDICAL CONDITION OR
MENTAL HEALTH CONDITION- AND SO
I DON'T THINK THERE'S I DON'T
THINK IT'S THE IT'S GOING TO BE
IMPLEMENTED IN A WAY THAT FILE
LOAD IN TERMS OF KIDS YOU KNOW
ID TEACH KIDS OR REGIONAL
CENTER KIDS. I THINK THE INTENT
IS TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE
SERVICES TO ALL KIDS IN A VERY
BAD SERVICE EVEN. EQUALLY
ACCEPTABLE WAY. MERKEL THANK
YOU FOR THAT I REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT BREAK DOWN.
AND
SOME. OF THE PUBLIC. OKAY THANK
YOU FOR. THAT SORT OF EXCUSE ME
SO MISSILE BITERS IN THE MISTER.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I'M SO
MUCH TO KIND OF GET BACK WE
WENT TO THIS SEEK WHAT
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT. THE
SEQUEL EXEMPTION FOR BROADBAND
I'M INDIAN MINISTER THE
REFINEMENTS FINANCE LET ME KNOW
IF THERE WAS ANY CONSIDERATION
BECAUSE THIS SECTION I BE
MISTAKEN BUT SECTION SIX OF SB
ONE FIFTY SIX IS EXTREMELY
AMBIGUOUS ON WHETHER OR NOT THE
SEQUENCE ACTION WOULD APPLY TO
THE LAST MILE. HAS THERE BEEN
GIVEN ANY CONSIDERATION OF
ALLOWING YOU TO LAST MILE
PROJECTS TO USE EXISTING
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT REPORTS
YOU KNOW MAYBE THREE TO FIVE
YEARS AS AN EFFORT TO GET MORE
SERVICES MORE QUICKLY- TO TWO
INDIVIDUALS SO CRYPTO CHRISTIAN
GRIFFITH AFTER THAT QUESTION
EARLIER BUT I WILL HAVE HIM
REPEAT TAX STATE I'M SIDE QUEST
FACT THAT THE SEQUEL EXEMPTION
ON THE BROADBAND BILL EXPLAIN.
EXACTLY HOW IT CAN BE USED ON
THE LAST MILE RIGHT TO IT IT'S
BASICALLY FOR RIGHT OF WAYS AND
SO IF THE RIGHT OF WAY IT IT
IT'S REALLY JUST TOO IT'S A
VERY NARROW AROUND RIGHT AWAY
ISN'T IT IT'S OPEN TO THE
MIDDLE MILE OR NONPROFITS FOR
REGULAR PROVIDERS WHO ARE DOING
A LAN CABLE ALONG RIGHT AWAY
RIGHT SO I UNDERSTAND THAT BUT
SO FOR OUR RURAL COMMUNITIES
THAT LAST MILE IS WHERE THERE
IS NO CONNECTIVITY RIGHT SO IF
YOU'RE LIVING IN A RURAL AREA
IN ALL GOOD WILL SAY. AND YOU
ARE TWO AND A HALF MILES AND
YOU KNOW PUTTING UP TO THE
NATIONAL FOREST- THAT FINAL
MILE GETTING ACCESS TO THAT
RESIDENT CONSTITUENT IS THE
MOST COMPLICATED HAVING TO DEAL
WITH THE QUOTE SO WHY NOT GIVE
CONSIDERATION TO ANY EXISTING
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT REPORTS
THAT COULD HELP EXPEDITE THAT
PROCESS WILL ONLY SPECIFICALLY.
AROUND THAT LAST MILE. IS I
THINK I MAY WHAT I'LL DO SAVE
FROM MY UNDERSTANDING IN TERMS
OF THIS PARTICULAR BILL THERE'S
A LOT OF THIS DIDN'T QUITE FIX
EVERY PROBLEM WE'RE GONNA HAVE
AN BROADBAND IN EVERY POSSIBLE
SITUATION SO THIS IS TRYING TO
GET A FRAMEWORK TOGETHER GIVEN
THAT THE SIX BILLION DOLLAR
PACKAGE BUT I DEFINITELY THINK
THE MORE TO CONVERSATION HAS TO
IS GOING TO HAPPEN AND
OBVIOUSLY MORE OVERSIGHT
BECAUSE AND THAT THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT'S GOING TO TAKE
YEARS TO FULLY BOOK FILLED OUT.
YOU KNOW IT'S ANTICIPATED THIS
COULD TAKE THREE YEARS SO I
THINK THIS IS THAT THAT'S A
GOOD POINT TO BRING UP TO THE
CONVERSATION BECAUSE I DO THINK
WE'RE GONNA HAVE SUBSEQUENT
LEGISLATION ON THIS GOING
FORWARD EXCELLENT AND THAT'S
JUST MY POINT IS THAT WE'VE
SEEN THROUGH THIS PANDEMIC YOU
KNOW OUR ROLE COMMUNITIES AND
WHAT PLACES WERE THERE ISN'T
CONNECTIVE ITTY- THAT IT WAS A
DETRIMENT TO THEM THIS PAST
YEAR SO ANYTHING WE CAN DO TO
EXPEDITE THAT IN A SAFE MANNER-
I THINK WE SHOULD MAKE
PRIORITY. MY NEXT QUESTION IS
I'M I'M REALLY HAPPY TO SEE
THAT THE NEW CHILD CARE SLOTS-
AND RATE INCREASES THAT ME AND
MY COLLEAGUES ON SUB TO HAVE
FOUGHT FOR SO HARD FOUGHT HARD
FOR WERE INCLUDED I'M BUT I AM
A LITTLE CONCERNED THAT YOU
KNOW WHEN I TALK TO PROVIDERS
SO WHEN I TALK TO YOU KNOW MY
FAMILY WHO HAS A CHILD CARE
CENTER- IT'S. REALLY HARD TO
HIRE. EARLY LEARN FOR. RIGHT
NOW. SO WHY DID THE
ADMINISTRATION REMOVE THE
FUNDING TO SUPPORT AND GROW THE
WORK FORCE IN THIS. THIS AND IN
SB ONE THIRTY WHAT. ACTUALLY
WITH A PERMANENT FINANCE AND I
WILL TURN THE QUESTION OVER TO
JENNIFER LOPEZ. OF COURSE GOOD
AFTERNOON JENNIFER LOPEZ
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WE DID
NOT REMOVE THE FUNDING TIED TO
THE WORK FORCE- THAT WAS MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT WAS DONE
AS PART OF THAT A TWENTY
NINETEEN BUDGET ACT. WHAT THIS
HAS DONE IS IT TO PRESERVE ALL
THE WORK AND THE EFFORT THAT
HAS BEEN DONE ON THE WORK FORCE
STATUTE IT'S MERELY LIFTING.
THIS LANGUAGE FROM EDUCATION
CODE AND PUT IT IN THE WELFARE
AND INSTITUTIONS CODE GIVEN
THAT THE PROGRAM WAS
TRANSITIONED FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION TO
SOCIAL SERVICES. SO IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT A LOT OF THE
LEGISLATURE IN ON Y
COLLEAGUES. ACROSS THE AISLE DO
YOU BOB WANT MORE FUNDING FOR
WORK FORCE BECAUSE IT'S A
PRIORITY AND REALLY. YOU KNOW
IF WE DON'T HAVE THE
PROFESSIONALS TO SERVE. YOU
KNOW. THE EVENTUALLY TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND CHILD CARE
SLOTS THAN THOSE SLOTS ARE
MEANINGLESS IF WE DON'T HAVE
THE WORKFORCE OF THE PERSONNEL
I'M SO IT GUESS THIS WILL BE A
CONTINUING THE CONVERSATION AND
I LOOK FORWARD TO IT- AT MY
LAST QUESTION IS AROUND SB ONE
SIXTY THE CANNABIS. BUDGET
BELT. IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
THOUSANDS OF ILLEGAL CANNABIS
GROWS HOUSE RUNG UP AROUND THE
DAY ARE DESERT COMMUNITIES.
CRACKING DOWN ON THESE GROWS-
LOCAL OFFICIALS AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT HAVE FOUND
INSTANCES OF FORCED LABOR A
CARTEL VIOLENCE WATER THEFT AND
THE DESTRUCTION OF FRAGILE
DESERT HABITATS AND WILDLIFE.
ARE LOCALS FEEL LESS SAFE IN
THEIR OWN COMMUNITIES BECAUSE
THE ILLEGAL GROWERS CARRY
WEAPONS REGULARLY EXCHANGED
GUNFIRE AND THREATEN HIKERS AND
LOCALS. AND SIGHTSEERS THEY'VE
EVEN SHOWN UP TO TOWN HALLS-
CARTEL MEMBERS ARMED I'M IT'S-
REALLY. BADIN SCARY IN OUR
COMMUNITIES IS THERE ANYTHING
IN THIS BUDGET THAT WILL
ADDRESS THE ILLEGAL GROWERS AND
OUR SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA DESERT
COMMUNITIES. YES ALTHOUGH THE
QUESTION OVER TO- MS HARBISON.
HI KIMBERLY HERBISON DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE THERE IS MONEY IN
THE BUDGETS- I LIKE I CAN
FOLLOW UP WITH YOU ON SPECIFICS
BUT THERE ARE ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS AT THE NEW DEPARTMENT
OF CANNABIS CONTROL THERE'S
ALSO MONEY FOR- FOR THE YEAR OF
STATE COMMUNITY CORRECTIONS
AND- WE ALSO WORK IN
PARTNERSHIP LARGELY WITH LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS AND IF. ANY OF MY
COLLEAGUES IN THE NEW
DEPARTMENT CANNABIS CONTROL
WOULD LIKE TO ADD ON THAT WOULD
BE. WELCOME AS WELL. YEAH I'M A
WHAT ABOUT OUR ARE THEY
AVAILABLE EARLY ON ON. YES-
EXCELLENT. AND I'M IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO WAY AND ALSO IS THERE
IF THERE'S IF YOU COULD LET ME
KNOW WHAT IF THERE'S A DOLLAR
AMOUNT FOR SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
WHERE THIS IS REALLY THE MOST
EXTREME LEVELS I WOULD
APPRECIATE THAT. SURE I'M
TERRIBLE SOMETHING DEPARTMENT
CANNABIS CONTROL- WE DO HOW THE
PEACE OFFICERS- THEY'RE LOCATED
THROUGHOUT THE STATE WORKING IN
DIFFERENT AREAS INCLUDING
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. A WE DON'T
HAVE A SEPARATE BUDGET FOR OUR
ENFORCEMENT ACTIVITIES IT IS
ONLY FOR SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AT
THIS POINT- BUT THOSE
ACTIVITIES ARE INCLUDED. IN OUR
BUDGET- FORMS FOR STUDENTS AND
WHAT IS YOUR TOTAL BUDGET. HEY
WE DON'T HAVE THAT NUMBER IN
FRONT OF ME FOR TOTAL
ENFORCEMENT BUDGET- BUT I THINK
WE CAN CERTAINLY GET BACK TO.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN THANK YOU FOR ALL THE
WORK YOU'VE DONE ON THE ON THE
BUDGET AND I KNOW THERE'S A LOT
MORE TO TELECOM- I WANT TO
RETURN TO THE DISCUSSION OF
AROUND TO AB ONE FORTY AND
EXPRESSED SIMILAR CONCERNS-
THAT TO THOSE THAT WERE
EXPRESSED EARLIER BY MY
COLLEAGUE FROM GLENDALE- BUT
FIRST OFF I WANT TO SAY THAT-
IT'S REMARKABLE THAT IN IN THIS
YEAR- WERE ABLE. TO A PROVIDED
ADDITIONAL FUNDING THIS IS TWO
BILLION DOLLARS OVER TWO YEARS
THAT'S ALL A LOT OF MONEY- AND
IT NEEDS TO BE STRESSED AS FAR
AS POSSIBLE AND THROUGH. ALL OF
OUR COMMUNITIES IN A- IN A FAIR
WAY. I'M AND WHETHER THE-
DIFFERENCES THIRTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS OR FIFTY SIX MILLION
DOLLARS THIS IS A LOT OF MONEY-
AT A TIME WHEN BUDGETS ARE
BEING STRETCHED THIN AND THIS
IS A TRUE IN EVERY CITY THAT
HAS A- HOMELESS POPULATION.
BUDGETS ARE BEING STRETCHED
THIN IN AN EFFORT TO ADDRESS
THE MANY ISSUES THAT. EXISTA
AMONGST THE ON HOUSED IN IN OUR
EFFORTS TO TRY AND RETURN-
THOSE WHO ARE ON OUR STREETS TO
HOUSING- I THINK IT'S EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT THAT WE VIEW THIS OR
THE THROUGH THE LENS OF EQUITY-
AND- LOS ANGELES SHOULD NOT BE
SHORT CHANGED BECAUSE- OF FOR
ANY REASON AT ALL- THIS SHOULD
JUST BE- FLAT OUT AN EQUITABLE
DISTRIBUTION AND THE- FACT THAT
THERE ARE OTHER. BUCKETS OF
FUNDS OUT THERE- I THINKTHAT'S
GREAT THAT'S ADDITIONAL MONEY
THAT CAN BE SOUGHT BY ANY
COMMUNITY BUT- THOSE FUNDS CAN
BE SOUGHT BY ANY COMMUNITY- AND
THAT SHOULD BE TRUE OF THE
MAIN- A SOURCE OF FUNDING THAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT HERE TO THE
TWO BILLION DOLLARS. I HAVE.
IT'S OUR HOPE THAT THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT THAT CAN BE
ADDRESSED I DO UNDERSTAND THAT-
THIS IS KIND OF A LEGACY FROM-
A PRIOR DISTRIBUTIONS TO
ADDRESS HOMELESSNESS- WHERE
THERE WAS A CAP PLACED TO- IN
TWO SUCCESSIVE YEARS. I ALSO
UNDERSTAND THAT- PART OF THE
ISSUE IS THAT THERE WAS NO
HOMELESS CAP IN- IN IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. AND SO WE'RE GOING
BACK- AND LOOKING AT WHAT
HAPPENED TO. IT WHAT THE COUNTS
FOR LIKE TWO YEARS AGO- THAT
SAID I THINK THERE'S A WAY TO
THERE SHOULD BE A WAY TO
BALANCE THIS OUT SO THAT IT IS
FAIR TO EVERY A COMMUNITY AND
CITY AND THE- THAT IS SAID NO
LESS THE CASE WITH. LAWCENTER
SHOULD BE NO LESS THE CASE WITH
LOS ANGELES. BERMAN SKODA-
MISTER BENNETT THE MISS REVERSE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF THIS
CHAIR AND I DO WANT TO THANK
YOU I KNOW IT'S SO ON GOING
STEADY WORK IN TERMS OF STAYING
AFTER THE BUDGET ARM I JUST
HAVE TO VERY BRIEF COMMENTS ONE
I- APPRECIATE THE INCLUSION OF-
IN THE ITEM ON THE ITEM EIGHT
AND RESOURCES OIL SPILL
PREVENTION ADMINISTRATIVE FUND
OF THE INCLUSION OF- HAVING THE
FEE BE A NEARLY INCREASE
CONSISTENT WITH THE CONSUMER
PRICE INDEX- I THINK THAT THE
CONCEPT THAT IS. BENEFICIAL FOR
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA IN
TERMS OF TRYING TO COME UP WITH
A BUDGET THAT IS- CAN BE A LONG
TERM SUSTAINABLE AND AVOID.
HAVING US HAVE THE SITUATIONS
WERE FEET DOESN'T CHANGE FOR
TWENTY YEARS AND THEY- THE
ACTIVITY THAT IS FUNDED BY THAT
FEET KEEPS INCREASING AND COST.
THEM WE GET THIS HUGE PROBLEM-
SO- TO THE EXTENT THAT STAFF AS
THE- RECEPTIVE TO THAT AND
INCLUDE CHAD AND AS MANY FEES
AS POSSIBLE I THINK CERTAINLY
THINK IT'S BENEFICIAL FOR
CALIFORNIA. OF HI ALSO- VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE THE- THEY WILL
WORK ON- THE DROUGHT- CONTRACT
RELIEF PROGRAM AND- UNDER THAT
I WOULD JUST LIKE TO OFFER-
THAT A DROUGHT BY DEFINITION IS
SOMETHING THAT IS TEMPORARY AND
IS EXPECTED TO GO AWAY. IT IS
ATION IS SOMETHING THAT IS A
SIGNIFICANT CHANGE IN THE
STATUS QUO AND I THINK HAT WE
HAVE TO AT LEAST BEGIN THE
PROCESS OF CONSIDERING- WHETHER-
SIGNIFICANT PARTS OF CALIFORNIA
MAY BE PARTICIPATING IN
ARABIZATION RATHER THAN A
DROUGHT SO AS WE MAKE THESE
REFERENCES TO DROUGHT- THE- WE
MAY HAVE TO BE TAKING LONGER
TERM THAN JUST. THIS IS A
TEMPORARY THING- BUT RATHER WE
NEED T START MAKING
ADJUSTMENTS FOR A JUST A
DIFFERENT AVERAGE RAINFALL THAN
WE'VE HAD IN THE LAST TWENTY
YEARS THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU MISS RIVAS. THANK YOU-MISTER CHAIR- I WANNA ALIGNED
MY CONCERNS WITH THE OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE L. A. COUNTY
DELEGATION THAT I'VE ALREADY-
DISCUSSED THE HOMELESSNESS
FUNDING CAP- IN AB ONE FORTY
FIVE YOU KNOW THE THERE'S A
CAP- OF IN TERMS OF THE AMOUNT
OF FUNDING THAT WILL GO TO THE
LOS ANGELES REGION. YOU KNOW AS
A RESULT THE CITY OF LA IS
CALCULATING A FIFTY MILLION
DOLLAR REDUCTION- IN THE AMOUNT
OF GRANTS THAT IT WOULD
RECEIVE- I KNOW THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE HAS STAFF HAS ALREADY
MENTIONED THAT THE CALCULATION
THAT THEY ARE OF COMING UP WITH
IS THIRTEEN MILLION DOLLARS
AND- YEAH I DON'T UNDERSTAND
WHY THAT DIFFERENCE AND I KNEW
IT. AND I WANT TO SEE THE
CHARTS THAT WERE THAT I KNOW
WITH MY COLLEAGUES FROM
GLENDALE REQUESTED TORE HER
OFFICE I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO SEE
THAT- TO UNDERSTAND- THE
DISCREPANCY BETWEEN THOSE TWO
CALCULATIONS- IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT LOS ANGELES IS THE
EPICENTER OF HOMELESSNESS IN
OUR STATE OF AND YOU KNOW I
THINK WERE ALL THOSE OF US IN
THE DELEGATION ARE VERY
CONCERNED ON THE REDUCTION IN
FUNDING. YOU KNOW THE CITY OF
LA IS SUGGESTING THAT THEIR
NUMBERS ARE RIGHT- BASED ON THE
LAST POINT ACCOUNT POINT IN
TIME COUNT ON HOMELESSNESS AND
JUST NO MATTER HOW MUCH THE
REDUCTION IS WHY SHOULD WE HAVE
A REDUCTION. YOU KNOW THERE ARE
OVER SIXTY THOUSAND HOMELESS
INDIVIDUALS YOU KNOW THE
MAJORITY OF HOMELESS
INDIVIDUALS- IN OUR STATE
RESIDE IN OUR COUNTY AND OUR
CITY HI AND SO- JUST WANT TO
ADD ON TO THAT- AND- AS YOU
KNOW AS CHAIR OF NATURAL
RESOURCES I HAVE CONCERNS WITH
THE SEQUEL EXEMPTIONS THAT ARE-
IN SEVERAL OF THESE TRAILER
BELLS- YOU KNOW SEEK WHAT IS
ONE OF THE FEW LEGAL TOOLS THAT
ALLOW THE PUBLIC. TO MEET BOTH
THEIR ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION
AND PUBLIC HEALTH NEEDS
PARTICULARLY FOR LOW INCOME
RESIDENTS AND COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR. I UNDERSTAND THE
IMPORTANT ISSUES THAT THESE
TRAILER BELLS ARE SEEKING TO
ADDRESS HOWEVER WE SHOULD NOT
BE SACRIFICING CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT OVERSIGHT TOOLS LIKE
SEEK WHILE IN ORDER TO ADVANCE
THESE PROPOSALS. THESE TYPES OF
DECISIONS SHOULD GO THROUGH
POLICY COMMITTEE SO WE CAN
EVALUATE THE IMPLICATIONS ALLOW
THE PUBLIC TO COMMENT OF N. YOU
KNOW I UNDERSTAND THAT THESE
BILLS WERE NEGOTIATED WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION. I JUST WANT
EXPRESSED MY FRUSTRATION THESE
BILLS WILL AVOID THE POLICY
COMMITTEE PROCESS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU- FIRST THIS IS THE-
FIRST TIME IN MY LIFE I'VE BEEN
ACCUSED OF BEING BAD AT MATH- I
ALSO WILL SAY THIS AS THE
PERSON WHO CHAMPION TOUGH
FLEXIBLE FUNDING FOR CITIES
COUNTIES. AND CONTINUES OF
CAMERA DRESSED DIRECTLY TO- LA
CITY AND TO THE MAYOR'S OFFICE
IS VERY DISAPPOINTING. TO HERE
OF THIS OBJECTION- THE DAY
BEFORE THE HEARING. AND AS
AGAIN AS THE LEAD CHAMPION FOR
FLEXIBLE FUNDING FOR THE CITIES
WE CAN OBVIOUSLY. ADDRESS THIS
IN THE FUTURE BUT WE THOUGHT
THAT THIS WAS AGAIN THE MOST
FAIR AND EQUITABLE DISTRIBUTION
FOR THE VARIETY OF CITIES WERE
INCLUDED AND AGAIN THE 45% CAP
IS ONLY. ON IN RELATION TO
CITIES- I HAD THE DEPARTMENT
FINANCE READ OFF THE FUNDING.
FOR THE VARIETY OF CITIES AND
MOSTLY OTHER CITIES ARE GETTING
I THINK BAKERSFIELD GOT SOME OF
THE SMALLER AMOUNTS LIKE AROUND
THREE MILLION- AGAIN SOME OF
THE SMALLER CITIES WORLDSTAR
FOUR FOUR MILLION FOUR. TWO
POINT NINE STARTER FOR NINE
THREE POINT NINE- BUT AGAIN
THIS SO WE FELT IT WAS A VERY
EQUITABLE. DISTRIBUTION BASED
ON THE SIZE AND THE SCOPE OF
THE PROBLEM- THROUGHOUT THE
STATE SOMEONE NOW GONNA
MYSTERONS. THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK YOU FOR
THE DISCUSSION AROUND
HOMELESSNESS AND- IT'S BEEN
STATED THAT THAT THE CENTER AND
ALL THOSE DIFFERENT THINGS BUT
WE ALL SHARE CITIES AND HAVE AT
THE CENTERS WITH HOMELESSNESS
AND POPULATION. SAMBAR DINO
COUNTY- AS COUNTY SUPERVISOR IN
THE INLAND EMPIRE REGION. FOR
THE INLAND EMPIRE COPIES AND
REMAINS THE NUMBER ONE ISSUE SO
LOOKING AT THE CONTINUUM CARE
AND SOME OF THE DIFFERENT
FUNDING THAT COMES TO
HOMELESSNESS. THAT CAN BE USED
WITH THE FEDERAL DOLLARS HAT
ARE COMING OUR WAY. IS
SOMETHING THAT WE LOOK FORWARD
TO- CERTAINLY- WITH THE
POPULATION PER CAPITA BASED
POPULATION IN LA IS ONE AREA
BUT WHEN YOU LOOK AT OTHER
AREAS WITHIN THE INLAND EMPIRE.
THAT CONTINUES TO GROW FROM
POINT IN TIME COUNTS WHEN WE'RE
ON THE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS TO WHERE IT IS NOW
THE POPULATION CONTINUES TO
GROW IT'S A CRISIS FOR MANY OF
US AND THE DISTRICTS WE
REPRESENT. SO WE CONTINUE TO
LOOK AT OF A FORMULA THAT
CONTINUES TO GIVE FUNDING TO
THE COUNTIES CONTINUE OF CARE
INTO THE CITY'S THAT MIGHT NOT
HAVE. THAT LARGE OF A
POPULATION BUT HAVE THE NEED TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEIR- CURBING-
THE HOMELESS- PROCESS IS MOVING
FORWARD. AND TO TALK ABOUT THE
LEGAL GROVES ARE GOING ON IN
THE HIGH DESERT A SAMBAR DINO
COUNTY. WE DO HAVE TO BE ABLE
TO LOOK AT THOSE AREAS
ESPECIALLY WHEN WE CREATE AN
OFFICE THAT HAS NOW
RESPONSIBILITY TO FOLLOW
THROUGH ON SOME OF THOSE AREAS.
IMPARTING WITH OUR LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AREAS ARE
CONTINUING CARE IN SEMINOLE
COUNTY IS SOMETHING THAT WE
WERE ON THAT WE CONTINUE TO-
GROW AND- AND MAKE SURE THAT
IT'S MOVING FORWARD IN THAT
RIGHT DIRECTION. HOWEVER OVER
YEARS THERE HAS BEEN THAT
DISPARITY OF EQUITY GOING BACK
AND FORTH THAT WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WERE CHIMING IN IN
THIS DISCUSSION TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE SUPPORTING THE
CHAIR. AND WHAT'S MOVING
FORWARD IN THIS BUDGET PROCESS
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE GET TO
THAT POINT WE WERE ALL
ADDRESSING THE HOMELESSNESS
ISSUE AND ALL OF OUR CITIES AND
ALL OF OUR DISTRICT HAS. ONE TO
MAKE THAT COMMENT MISTER CHAIR.
I MYSTERON US- ANY OTHER
COMMENTS ON THE COMMITTEES.
OKAY A SINGLE OR FURTHER
COMMENT WE WILL NOW GO TO
PUBLIC COMMENT OF ANY PUBLIC
COMMENT IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN OF
THE COMMITTEE JEREMY SMITH HER
BEHALF OF THE STATE BUILDING
AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES
COUNCIL- HERE ARE THE TRIO OF
BILLS FIRST- IN SUPPORT OF AB
AND SB ONE FIFTY SIX THE
BROADBAND TRAILER BILL THANK
YOU FOR YOUR HARD WORK ON THOSE
BILLS- IN SUPPORT OF AB ONE
THIRTY TWO. THE HIGHER
EDUCATION TRAILER BILL THAT
DOES HAVE SIX SECTION SIXTY
SEVEN REMOVED FROM ITS
PROVISIONS. AND WE REMAIN
STRONG OPPOSITION TO SECTION
SIXTY SEVEN OF SB ONE THIRTY
TWO S. B. ONE THREE TO THE
HIGHER EDUCATION TRAILER BILL
THAT YOU HEARD. LAST WEEK IN AS
THE FORTY TODAY AS WELL.
SECTION SIXTY SEVEN OF SB ONE
THIRTY TWO WOULD LEVERAGE THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
CONSTRUCTION BUDGET. TO ADVANCE
THE PRIORITIES OF THE BILL'S
NOT BEFORE US TODAY IT WAS ON
YOUR AGENDA. IT'S NOT ON THE-
TO BE HONEST ENOUGH TO KEEP
GOING NO OKAY I JUST WANTED TO
IT APPEARED ON THE AGENDA IS
ONE IT'S GONNA BE HEARD NOT ON
MY TENT OKAY- BY PLACING ALL
THE CONSTRUCTION CAPITAL THE
FUNDS FOR YOU SEEN AN- ESCROW
ACCOUNT WITH THE STATE
COMPTROLLER AND TELL YOU SEE IN
A THIRD PARTY CAN CERTIFIED ONE
HUNDRED. PERCENT DIRECT
EMPLOYMENT FOR ALL SERVICE
WORK. AT EVERY YOU SEE FACILITY
WITH NO EXCEPTIONS. IS
IMPORTANT NOTE THAT THIS REASON
CONSTRUCTION WOULD PROBABLY
EVEN CRITICALLY NEEDED SEISMIC
UPGRADES EASY HOSPITALS. MAYOR
THANKFUL THAT THE BILL OF THE
LANGUAGE IS BEEN REMOVED FROM
AB ONE THIRTY TWO- THAT'S IN
THE POSSESSION OF THE SENATE-
NOW IS BECAUSE NOW ISN'T THE
TIME TO PUT LEVEL WONDERFUL
WORKERS LIVELIHOODS. OR ANY
POTENTIAL BENEFITS AND THE
PUBLIC SAFETY. IS FOR THESE
REASONS THAT WE SUPPOSED TO
CIVICALLY SB A SECTION SIXTY
SEVEN AS WELL ONE THIRTY TWO
AND URGED TO REMOVE IT BEFORE
FINAL PASSAGE OF THE MAYOR'S.
AB ONE THIRTY TWO. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEED A PUBLIC COMMENT.
LET'S GO TO THE PHONES OPERATOR
EITHER. THANK YOU LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO MAKE A
COMMENT YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE CURRENTLY
HAVE ABOUT TEN COMMENTS THANK
YOU. GO AHEAD OPERATOR. THANK
YOU I'M THIRTY TWO GOING. ABOUT
THE MOMENT CHAIRMAN AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
WHAT IT BUT HELLO ON THE OF THE
UNITED DOMESTICWORKERS ASK
LOCAL NINE. WE ARE FOR THE
BUDGET COMMITTEE THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE- WORK THE
YEAR TO MAKE SUCH PROCTOR
PROGRESS. THE ITEMS THAT. AB
ONE THIRTY. THE CIVIC LIKE WE
ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
PERMANENT RESTORATION OF THE 7%
CUT. AS A CO PAYMENT TO MOVE
NEGOTIATIONS FORWARD
CONTINUATION OF THE CURRENT
COST SHARING RATIO. IN RELATED
BARGAINING TOOLS ADDITIONALLY
WE SUPPORT AB ONE THIRTY ONE TO
INCREASE REIMBURSEMENT RATES TO
FAMILY CHILD CARE PROVIDERS AND
TO BABBAGE. JOINT LABOR
MANAGEMENT COMMITTEE SB
PERFECTED IN THE TENTATIVE
AGREEMENT WITH THE STATE.
FINALLY WE ARE SUPPORTIVE OF AB
ONE SIXTY TO ENSURE CANNABIS
LABOR PROTECTION AS WELL AS
INSURANCE HEALTH AND SAFETY OF
THE PUBLIC AND THE ENVIRONMENT.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO FUTURE
DISCUSSIONS AROUND ELECTRONIC
VISIT VERIFICATION I COUPLE BY
THE- AND PAUL AND- SERVICE
FUNDING WITH THE CHAIRMAN. AND
COMMITTED THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO MAKE A COMMENT.
THANK YOU BRIAN THIRTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
CHAIR KING COMMITTEE MEMBERS
COMMITTEE STAFF AND BUDGET
CONSULTANTS FOR ALL OF YOUR
HARD WORK IN CRAFTING THIS
YEAR'S BUDGET THIS IS JENNIFER
MALLEY THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION. WE HAVE SEVERAL
BUDGET ITEMS THAT THE TRYING TO
BUDGET PACKAGES THAT WOULD LIKE
TO EXPRESS OUR SUPPORT FOR AND
SENATE BILL ONE FIFTY FOUR WE
SUPPORT THE TEN MILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENT FOR WORKERS AT THE
SANTA CLARA VTA WHO EXPERIENCED
UNSPEAKABLE TRAGEDY LAST MONTH.
AND WILL HAVE FUNDING TO HELP
THESE EMPLOYEES ARE COVERED
RETURNED TO WORK WITH SUPPORT
AB ONE THIRTY THREE ESPECIALLY
THE ELIMINATION OF THE MEDIC
CAL AFFECT CATS. AS WELL AS THE
EXPANSION OF MEDICARE TO
INCLUDE ALL INCOME ELIGIBLE.
ADULTS ABOVE THE AGE OF FIFTY.
WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF AB ONE
THIRTY FIVE. THIS LANGUAGE
PERMANENTLY RESTORED THE 7% HFF
KIND IMPLEMENTS PROVISIONS TO
HELP MOVE COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
FORWARD FOR HOME CARE
PROVIDERS. INCLUDING A FISCAL
PENALTY IN CONTINUATION OF
MACCAFERRI BARGAINING TOOL. WE
ALSO SUPPORT EIGHTY ONE THIRTY
ONE AS IT REFLECTS THE CHILD
CARE BARGAINING AGREEMENTS AND
THE INCREASING REIMBURSEMENT
RATES THE FAMILY CAP CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS. WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE COMMITTEE AND
CHAPTER OF OFFICE TO ENSURE
THAT AS WE FIND WAYS TO BRING
PEOPLE BACK TO WORK. THAT
pTHEY'RE RETURNING TO JOB
OPPORTUNITIES THAT ARE
CONSIDERED HIGH ROAD. AS WELL
AS THE INSURANCE THAT THE
UNPRECEDENTED INVESTMENT AND
CONSTRUCTION OF BROADBAND HAVE
WAGE HOUR AND JOB PROTECTIONS
AND GO TO CALIFORNIA BASED
WORKERS. WITH THAT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND HAVE A WONDERFUL
EVENING. THANK YOU NINE THIRTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS
IS JUSTIN GET WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES THAT WE APPRECIATE THE
STRONG INVESTMENT FOR
VULNERABLE CHILDREN OLDER
ADULTS AND HUMAN SERVICES
TRAILER BILL SPECIALLY
INCLUSION OF OUR SPONSOR BUDGET
PROPOSAL TO PROVIDE CONTINUITY
FOR THAT IS THAT STATE COUNTY
CHURN RATIO AND 10% OVER THREE
YEARS TO. HOWEVER WE DO REMAIN
STRONGLY OPPOSED TO THE HIGHEST
THAT'S THE SCHOOL COUNTY
PROVISIONS OF AB ONE THIRTY
FIVE S. B. ONE THIRTY FIVE. I
COUNTY THE REACHED AGREEMENTS
FAR ABOVE THE HISTORIC PACE
OVER THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS
INVESTED HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS FOR WAGE INCREASES
FOR RIGHTS OF PROVIDERS. THIS
PROVISION OF THE SEVEN FOLD
INCREASE OVER THE PRIOR PENALTY
AND PUNISHES ALL THOSE COUNTY
THE DID THE RIGHT THING AND
INCREASE WAGES FOR PROVIDERS.
NOT JUST A VERY SMALL NUMBER
THAT HAVE YET TO REACH AN
AGREEMENT. SIMPSON TELL MLB
USED TO LEVERAGE COUNTIES INTO
A GREEN TO WAIT INCREASE OF THE
SOME COUNTIES CAN'T AFFORD
WITHOUT TAKING MONEY FROM OTHER
PROGRAMS. THIS CREATES RISK FOR
OTHER PROGRAMS WITHIN
REALIGNMENT. IT WAS OPENED LAST
GROWTH FUNDING BEING AVAILABLE
FOR PUBLIC HEALTH AND BEHAVIOR
HEALTH PROGRAMS. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU
RUNNING FORTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE BUDGET COMMITTEE
MY NAME IS CHRISTOPHE MAIRE AND
I AM CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN FEDERATION OF STATE
COUNTY AND MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES.
AFTER THE PORTS THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF THE CHILDREN
AND YOUTH BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
INITIATIVE ACT. AS WELL AS THE
FRAMEWORK FOR THE BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH CONTINUUM INFRASTRUCTURE
PROGRAM WITHIN AB ONE THIRTY
THREE. WE STRONGLY SUPPORT AB
ONE THIRTY ONE TO INCREASE
REIMBURSEMENT RATES FOR CHILD
CARE PROVIDERS. AND TO ALLOW
FOR A JOINT LABOR MANAGEMENT
COMMITTEES REFLECTING THE
RECENT BARGAINING AGREEMENTS.
AFTER ME ALSO STRONGLY SUPPORTS
AB ONE THIRTY FIVE WHICH
IMPROVES THE IN HOME SUPPORTIVE
SERVICES PROGRAM. EQUITY IN THE
PERMANENT RESTORATION OF THE 7%
SERVICE CUTS AND THE INCLUSION
OF CRITICAL BARGAINING TOOLS
THE FISCAL PENALTY FOR COUNTIES
THAT BARGAINED IN BAD FAITH AND
MAINTAINING THE COST SHARING
RATIO. FINALLY WE WOULD LIKE TO
EXPRESS APPRECIATION TO THE
PARTY CONTINUED WORK OF THIS
COMMITTEE TO ENSURE THAT THE
BUDGET REFLECTS THE VALUES OF
THE STATE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
RAIN CHECKS STATE YOU'LL PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON RUN
AWAY WITH WESTERN CENTER ON LAW
AND POVERTY WE WANT TO EXPRESS
OUR APPRECIATION TO THE
LEGISLATURE COMMITTEE STAFF AND
ADMINISTRATION BUDGET SURPLUS
INCOME CALIFORNIANS
SPECIFICALLY WANT TO EXPRESS
OUR STRONG SUPPORT FOR A BI SB
ONE THIRTY THREE INCLUDING
ELIMINATING THE MEDICARE ACT
THAT TASK. AND MEDICARE
ADVANTAGE CRISTINA OVER FIFTY
AND ONE THIRTY FIVE INCLUDES
ACCESS I RESTORATION AND CAL
WORK INCREASE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU A LINE. THREE IS FOR HAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS BUT AT WORK
BEHIND POKORNY TEAM- WE SENATE-
THE. THIRTY TWO. OTHER AND HOPE
TO WORK WITH COMMITTEE THANK
YOU. THANK RANGE EIGHT I HAD.
AFTER MISTER CHAIR THE RIGHT TO
JOHN GOOD PRESS OF NORTH CAL
BUILDING TRADES CAL. ART THOU
OF MEMBERS BEGAN ITS UP THE-
YEAH. SECTION SIXTY SEVEN OF SB.
ONE THIRTY TWO THANK YOU. THANK
YOU RYAN THIRTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS RAYMOND DAVIS I'M WITH IRON
WORKERS LOCAL ONE EIGHTEEN AND
WE STAND WITH THE BUILDING
TRADES IN OPPOSITION OF SB ONE
THIRTY TWO SECTION SIXTY SEVEN.
THANK YOU. SIR FOR ALL RIGHT BY
OPERATOR SO FOR EVERYBODY ON
HOLD TO TALK ABOUT SB ONE
THIRTY TWO THAT IS NOT AN ITEM
ON THE AGENDA SO I'M NOT TAKING
COMMENT ON SB ONE THIRTY TWO.
THAT EVERYBODY WAS ALLOW
COMMENT WHEN WE HAD THE HEARING
LAST WEEK. SO WE WILL- ASSUME
THAT THAT REMAINS THE SAME
COMMENT. BUT WE'RE NOT TAKING
ANY COMMENT ON THIS BE ONE
THIRTY TWO BECAUSE IT'S NOT ON
THE AGENDA. GO AHEAD OPERATE.
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO REMOVE
YOURSELF FROM THE QUEUE PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME THAT WILL BRING MOBILE.
WE'LL GO TO LINE THIRTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
GOING MOBILE OF IRONWORKERS
UNION LOCAL THREE SEVENTY EIGHT
STANDING WITH THE BUILDING
TRADE- ON THEIR COMMENT SECTION
ON ALL LEGISLATION IN QUESTION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU RYAN SIXTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON THAT A HUNDRED AND
WITH WIDENING GROUP ON BEHALF
OF THAT IN CALIFORNIA WE WANT
TO THANK THE COMMITTEE STAFF
LEGISLATURE AND ADMINISTRATION
FOR THE SIX BILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENT IN BROADBAND-
NOTHING SUPPORT ATSC ONE
FIFTIES THAT WOULD BE THAT THAT
DOOR BUT INSTALLATION OF THE
MEDICINE THAT THEY CAN
INVESTMENT. IN PUBLIC.
BROADBAND INFRASTRUCTURE IN THE
COUNTRY. THE BILL WILL BENEFIT
RESIDENTS ACROSS WITH TO YOU
BUT IF. YOUR TICKETS BROWN
ACCESS TRANSFER THE WAY. SCHOOL
SMALL BUSINESSES HEALTHCARE
ORGANIZATIONS AND OTHER. AT
OTHER CAN PROVIDE THE
CONSERVATIVE STATEWIDE THIS
LEGISLATION WILL CONNECT
MILLIONS OF FAMILIES AND
BUSINESSES BY PROVIDING TWO
BILLION DOLLARS FOR THE LAST
MILE NETWORK CONSTRUCTION AND
BOTH RURAL AND URBAN CENTERS OF
CALIFORNIA. BLACK MOUNTBATTEN'S
DOLLARS WILL BE EVEN BETTER
LEVERAGE BY THE THREE POINT TWO
FIVE BILLION DOLLARS EARMARKED
TO CONSTRUCT. ITS STATE WIDE
OPEN ACCESS MIDDLE MILE NETWORK
WHICH IS AN ESSENTIAL FIRST
STEP TOWARDS INCREASING
CONNECTIVITY AND AFFORDABILITY
FOR ALL BY MAKING IT EASIER FOR
MORE INTERNET PROVIDERS BRIGHT
FASTER. CHEAPER SERVICE
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. BUILDING
AND OPEN ACCESS MIDDLE MILE
NETWORK ALSO CREATES
OPPORTUNITIES FOR MORE ENTITIES
TO THE LAST MILE INFRASTRUCTURE
MOST PLACES. SEXUAL IMPORTANCE
AT THEM IN COMBAT PROVIDERS
HAVE THE PARKLIFE EXPANSION
GIVE. DURING AREAS IN OUR STATE.
AN ADDITIONAL SEVEN HUNDRED
FIFTH MILLION DOLLAR WILL ACT.
AS A LONG MONSTER SPECIFICALLY
DEFINE TO LEVEL EVEN BY
INFRASTRUCTURE AND BY. BY LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TRIBAL GOVERNMENT
THE NONPROFIT. THIS LEGISLATION
UTILIZES THE FIVE POINT TWO
FIVE BILLION DOLLARS IN ONE
TIME FEDERAL FUNDS TO PROVIDE A
PERMANENT BENEFIT BY BUILDING
BROADBAND INFRASTRUCTURE
THROUGHOUT EVERY REGION OF THE
STATE AND FOR ALL THESE REASONS
WE I. STRONGLY URGE YOUR
SUPPORT OF AB AT THE ONE FIFTY
SIX AND URGE THE BUT PASSAGE OF
THAT THANK YOU. THANK YOU RYAN
ONE. POINT FIFTY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MISTER TERRY MEMBERS
RANDY MARTIN ON BEHALF OF CMG
KHALIFA ONE OF THE LARGEST
CANNABIS COMPANIES IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. REGRETTABLY AND
WITH GREAT DISMAY OPPOSED TO AB
ONE SIXTY S. SB ONE SIXTY WE
REMAIN DEEPLY TROUBLED BY THE
AMENDMENTS RELATIVE TO THE
EXTENSION OF PROVISIONAL
LICENSES FOR CULTIVATORS OF ONE
OF MORE THAN ONE ACRE- THEY ARE
GOING TO BE COMPRESSED INTO A
VERY LIMITED TIME FRAME IN
ORDER TO TRANSITION TO- THEY-
ANNUAL LICENSE- AT LOCAL AND
STATEGOVERNMENTS STRUGGLE TO
TRANSITION THOUSANDS. OF THESE-
PROVISIONAL CULTIVATION
LICENSES TO ANNUAL LICENSES
WITHIN THAT COMPRESSED TIME
FRAME- NUMEROUS RESPONSIBLE
CULTIVATORS ARE GONNA LOSE
THEIR LICENSE YOUR NO FAULT OF
THEIR OWN CAUSING THE LOSS OF
TENS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN
TAX GENERATION ON BOTH STATE
AND LOCAL THE LOSS OF THOUSANDS
OF JOBS AND THE LOSS OF
MILLIONS OF POUNDS OF BIOMASS
WITH DELETERIOUS IMPACT ON THE
DOWNSTREAM RETAILERS AND
MANUFACTURERS. WE URGE YOU TO
OPPOSE- AB ONE SIXTY SB ONE
SIXTY AS LONG AS. THAT
PROVISION REMAINS IN THE BILL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
FIFTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS IT LOOKS IN A GLITCH
THE CALIFORNIA COMPANY TO COME
TO COURT COULD NOT VERIFY THE
PLAN SB ONE B. E. L. IT WILL.
PAST PERFORMANCE WE WANT TO
APPLAUD THAT BUILD INCLUSION.
EIGHT CHARTER CRITICS REQUIRE
FUEL TANK TOP OF THE NATION'S
CHANGING CHECK ACROSS THE STATE
ASSEMBLY SYSTEM INCLUDING
HOSPITALS. GROUPS HOW
COMPETITIVE OTHER MAJOR
PROVIDERS AND PAYERS I THANK
THE HARPER THE COMMITTEE AND
STAFF SELECTION AT LEADERSHIP
AND PUBLIC ADMINISTRATION I'M
TALKING ITS FRAMEWORK FOR THE
BILL I LOOK FORWARD TO BE PART.
OF THE PROCESS THAT WILL SEEK
HELP IN ACTION. BEHIND
EQUIPMENT. BUT WE ALSO HI THERE.
CANESCENS AND HEALTH THAT ARE
IMPORTANT PART HOW PLAN MEDICAL
PLAN DO CHECK THAT HELP ARE TO
HIGH. GLOBAL HEALTH THANK YOU.
THANK YOU RIGHT EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN TO MEAL THE CAL STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES I'LL BE
BRIEF BUT I WANT TO THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
YOUR STAFF AND EVERYONE ELSE
WHO DID THE ARTWORK TO COME TO
AN AGREEMENT ON. A B. S. B. ONE
FIFTY SIX- PASSING THIS MEASURE
BEFORE SOME RESETS WILL ALLOW
THE ACTED AGENCIES TO BEGIN THE
IMPORTANT WORK OF NEGOTIATING
CONTRACTS OF PLANNING AND
STAFFING UP. IN THE STATE NOT
ONLY TO BEGIN CONNECTING
CALIFORNIANS MORE QUICKLY BUT
ALSO PUT THE STATE IN A
POSITION TO DRAW DOWN EVEN MORE
FEDERAL FUNDS FOR BROADBAND
PROJECTS AND IMPORTANTLY RESIST
EFFORTS TO CALL BACK FUNDS AS
IT'S BEEN MENTIONED AND-
FEDERAL DISCUSSIONS ABOUT HOW
TO PAY FOR THE INFRASTRUCTURE.
PLAN HELLO AGAIN THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. IN SUPPORT OF THE S. B.
ONE SIX. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CARE MEMBER
CARE AT THE HOSPITAL BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION IN VERY STRONG
SUPPORTER A. B. SLASH SB ONE
FIFTY SIX. THE FUNDING THAT IS
PROVIDED IN THIS FOR THE MIDDLE
MILE THE LAST MILE CONNECTIONS
WILL ENSURE THAT ALL OF OUR
STUDENTS. ARE ABLE TO ACCESS
ALL THE EDUCATIONAL PROGRAM GET
THEIR HOMEWORK DONE AND DO
RESEARCH PROJECTS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR WORK ON THIS
AND AGAIN CSKA'S IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE MEASURE. THANK
YOU RYAN FIFTY NINE BASEBALL
HAT. SHARE MEMBERSHIP ENTER
INTO HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF
LOS ANGELES MAYOR ERIC GARCETTI
I WANT TO START OFF BY THANKING
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRIEDMAN
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOM ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RIVAS AND ALL THE
LEGISLATORS WHO SPOKE UP.
DURING THIS MEETING A BEHIND
THE SCENES OF THE RAISE THE
ISSUE OF A CAP ON ALLOCATIONS
THE LOS ANGELES REGION- WE ALSO
WANT TO THANK CHAIRMAN PAYING
AND BUDGET STAFF WHO SPENT
COUNTLESS HOURS ALONG WITH
ADMINISTRATION GETTING AT THIS
POINT. WE APPRECIATE THE CHAIRS
RECOGNITION THAT L. A. BEARS A
DISPROPORTIONATE REGION OF THE
STATE'S. HOMELESS POPULATION.
OF THE CAPS- DO AN RQ SEVEN
ARTIFICIAL LIMITS ON FUNDS THAT
WOULD FLOW BASED ON GOOD FOR
CAPITA SHARE OF THE HOMELESS
POPULATION EXPAT- BUT WHEN
YOU'RE WRONG YOU'RE WRONG. WE
HAVE TO ADMIT. WE APOLOGIZE TO
THE LEGISLATORS WHO USED OUR
NUMBERS WE- VERY MUCH WANT TO
TAKE IT BUT THE STAFF UP ON THE
OFFER TO SIT DOWN. AND GO TO
THE CHARTS WE DID OUR BEST TO
CALCULATE THE IMPACT. BASED ON
A LANGUAGE THAT CAME IN A PRINT
SUNDAY AT NINE PM- AND WE WILL
DO EVERYTHING WE CAN TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE GET OUT I
CORRECTED LATTER. AND AGAIN-
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
AND WE I THINK WE ALL AGREE
THAT. FUNDING. FOR HOMELESSNESS
EFFECTIVE SUPPORT THE FIGHT.
AND IT'S WORTH OF PROACTIVE
ABOUT WE ALL WANT TO BE
ACCURATE. AND WITH THAT I JUST
WANT TO THANK EVERYBODY FOR THE
FORBEARANCE AND WE WILL
CONTINUE AND WE DO BELIEVE THAT
THIS FORTY FIVE PERCENT. CAP IS
THE CARRYOVER FROM PREVIOUS
BUDGET YEARS. YEAH THIS IS THE
LARGEST ALLOCATION ARE WE
SEEING THE MANY YEARS THAT IT
COULD SET A PRECEDENT SO WE
JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
NUMBERS ARE RIGHT. AND WE WILL.
WE'LL SPEAK UP WHEN WE GET IT
WRONG WE WILL GET THE
ASSISTANCE THAT'S BEING OFFERED
HERE AND MAKE SURE THAT THE
HELP GETS. THE BOTH FIFTY TO.
MAKE IT- THANK YOU RYAN FIFTY
SIX CALL. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN ONTO THOUSAND OF US
YEAH YOU CAN WE WANT TO EXPRESS
OUR STRONG SUPPORT FOR SB ONE
SIXTY REGARDING THE DEPARTMENT
CANNOT CONTROL WE APPRECIATE
AND SUPPORT THE STATE CONTINUED
WORKING INCREASE ENFORCEMENT ON
REQUIREMENTS FOR WORKER
PROTECTION FOR THE CREATION OF
A PATHWAY FOR EQUITY APPLICANTS
YOU CAN BUY MUCH OF COMPLIANCE
AND FOR ADDING CLARITY AND
HELPING PUBLIC SAFETY
PROTECTIONS ON PROVISIONS
RELATED TO TRANSIT ON. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU RANGE SIXTY
CHILL PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
THURMOND MCDADE PAYING WHAT THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES- TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT
OF- THE HELP TRAILER BILL AB SP
ONE THIRTY THREE FOUR SPECIALLY
STRONG SUPPORTER OF THE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE CONTINUE ON
PROGRAM AND THE CHILD'S MOTHER
IN YOUR NEIGHBORHOOD INITIATIVE
THESE TWO. PROGRAMS COULD
CHANGE HOW TO BE A HELP IS
OFFERED IN CALIFORNIA WE'RE
VERY EXCITED TO BEGIN THE WORK
ON IMPLEMENTATION I WILL ALSO
NOTE THAT THE FACT IS NEUTRAL
ON THE I. F. T. PROPOSAL- WHICH
THE COMMITTEE DISCUSSED AT
SEVERAL POINTS TODAY HOWEVER
WE'RE LOOKING FORWARD TO THE
EFFORTS OF THE WORK PROPOSED
WORKING GROUP. TO FIND A
SOLUTION THAT WORKS BEFORE NOT
ONLY DEPARTMENT THE HOSPITALS
AND COUNTIES BUT OF COURSE THE
VULNERABLE PEOPLE. THE AUTHOR
THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
CRIMINAL LIABILITY CHILD
LAWCENTER ARE COMMON IN YOUR
GARDEN AB ONE THIRTY ONE WE
WANT TO THANK THE LEGISLATURE
FOR SUBSTANTIAL INVESTMENTS IN
CHILD CARE ESPECIALLY WITH THE
INCREASE IN CHILD CARE SPACES
AND GREAT. THIS IS A HISTORIC
YEAR AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
SEEING MORE DETAIL WELL WE ARE
VERY APPRECIATIVE OF THE WAY
BIRTH FAMILY FEES FOR ONE YEAR
WE ARE DISAPPOINTED THAT THEY
ARE NOT WAIT FOR A SECOND YEAR
OR THAT AN EQUITABLE THE FAMILY
PLEASE CASUAL THAT CAP. AT
SEVEN PERCENT. OF FAMILY INCOME
IS INCLUDED ESPECIALLY GIVEN
PREVIOUS BUDGET DISCUSSIONS.
AND FEDERAL MOUNTED AND- THANK
YOU MUCH. THANK YOU RYAN SIXTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME
IS TURNING COAL BURNING THE IO
OF THE CALIFORNIA ALTERNATIVE
PAYMENT PROGRAM ASSOCIATION.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE
HISTORICAL INVESTMENT IN
CHILDCARE RATE TITANS IN CHILD
CARE SLOTS BIRD LOWER INCOME
FAMILIES TO ACCESS. WE ALSO
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE PROPOSED
THREE REFORMS OF THAT
SIMPLIFICATION AND SPECIAL
THANKS TO SENATOR LAID BACK AND
THE LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S CAUCUS
FOR TAKING THE LEAD FOR THE
CHANGE WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
SENATE BILL ONE THREE ONE WE
JUST NEED TO BRING YOUR
ATTENTION TO THE CONCERNS OF
ADDING A HUNDRED AND TWENTY
THOUSAND CHILD CARE SLOTS FOR
FAMILIES TO BEGIN ACCESSING ON
JANUARY ONE. WITH NO INCREASE
IN FUNDING FOR COMMUNITY
AGENCIES TO BEGIN RAMPING UP TO
TAKE ON THE WORK THAT WILL MORE
THAN TRIPLE THE EXISTING
CAPACITY OF THESE CONTRACTORS
AGAIN THANK YOU FOR YOUR WORK.
AND OUR MOST HEARTFELT
APPRECIATION. THANK YOU RYAN
SIXTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON CAN LAST REPRESENTING
THE CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR
YEAR AND QUARTER AT ONE FORTY
AND PARTICULARLY APPRECIATE BAG
LEGISLATURE THE PENSION AND
CONSIDERATION OF THE NEEDS OF
OUR YOUNG PEOPLE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS YOU'RE A STARK AND
BACKGROUND. OF AT LEAST 10% IN
THE HOME OF THE FUNDING TOWARD
OUR YOUNG PEOPLE ON THE STREET.
AS WELL AS THE- AT LEAST 8% BUT
ASIDE IN THE PROJECT HOME HE
FINDS I REALLY JUST HOPE THAT
ARE AND YOU HOMELESSNESS
SERVICE PROVIDERS WHO HAVE
DEMONSTRATED EXPERIENCE
PROVIDING HOUSING FOR YOUNG
PEOPLE ARE ABLE TO TAP INTO
THOSE RESOURCES IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT BECAUSE THEY
UNDERSTAND THE NEEDS OF OUR
YOUNG PEOPLE AND- THE HOPPING
OPTION BAY. THAT'LL MAKE THEM
BE. ABOUT THE CRAP THANK YOU.
THANK YOU RUNNING FORTY NINE
TREES FOR HAD. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR- MISTER
JERRY MEMBERS MARKED THE GLORIA
REPRESENTING THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
AND- EXPRESSING OUR GRATITUDE
FOR ALL THE HARD WORK THAT- YOU
AND THE STAFF HAVE PUT TO GET
THE BUDGET THAT- HAS BEEN DONE
BEFORE US TO HELP- BUILDS IN
THE CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM THEIR
SENIORS. ARE DALTON CAL WORKS
PROGRAM AND- DOCTOR TO SERVICES
AND HELPING TO HELP THIS ISSUE
AND- ALL ALL THE OF THE OTHER
PROGRAMS- INCLUDING CHILD CARE
I ALSO WANT TO RAISE AN ISSUE
RELATED TO AB ONE FORTY AND
THAT'S WHAT THE STATEMENT THAT
MY COLLEAGUES. ARE MISTER ENTRY
REYES ON BEHALF OF DALY CITY
AND WE WOULD DEFINITELY LIKE TO
WORK WITH YOU- FINDING OUT THE
EXACT FIGURES- BUT ALSO ADDRESS
THE NEED FOR THE FUNDING- TO
ADDRESS HOMELESSNESS AND.
ALICANTE THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT THREE PLAYS
FOR AT. I DIDN'T ON BEHALF OF
THE- ROLL CALL OF THE K.
DEMOCRATIC PARTY WERE IN
SUPPORT OF THE S. B. AB ONE
FIFTY SIX THANK YOU FOR YOUR
WORK AND- THIS IS A LONG
AWAITED- EFFORT THAT- REALLY
NEEDS TO BE COMPLETED THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU RYAN SIXTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. BUYING
SIXTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YOUR MEMBER MARC SMITH ON
BEHALF THE ORIGINS COUNSEL
REPRESENTING SIX HUNDRED
LICENSE AND ANCILLARY CANNABIS
BUSINESSPERSON WAITING WITHIN
THE STORE CANNABIS FARMING
REGIONS OF CALIFORNIA WHAT
APPRECIATE ALL THE WORK FOR
THIS PRODUCT TO WHERE WE ARE ON
ONE SIXTY. EIGHTY AND EIGHTY
ONE SIXTY WE ARE SUPPORTIVE OF
THE TIMELINE EXTENSION FOR THE
LAUNCH OF THE CANNABIS
APPELLATIONS PROGRAM- WE DO
APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT
PROVISIONS TO ENSURE THE
COMPLIANCE BENCHMARKS ARE
BROADLY APPLICABLE TO ALL
JURISDICTIONAL APPROACHES
RELATED TO SEE WHAT COMPLIANCE
WE KNOW THAT THIS WAS AN ISSUE
RELATED TO ONE FORTY ONE WHICH
WAS APPROVED BY THE LEGISLATURE
SEVERAL WEEKS AGO HOWEVER. WE
DO HAVE CONCERNS OF THE TIME
LINES FOR THESE COMPLAINTS THAT
MARKS CONTINUE TO BE
UNREALISTIC PROVISIONAL
LICENSEES ARE DENIED THE RIGHT
OF APPEAL AND UNDER THIS
MEASURE WE CONTINUE TO FACE
GREATLY INCREASE RECKLESS OF
LICENSING INTERRUPTION OR LOSS
DUE TO NO FAULT OF OUR OWN
SHOULD LOCAL JURISDICTIONS ARE
STATE AGENCIES EXPERIENCE
CHALLENGES IN MEETING THESE
TIME LINES OF THESE COMPLIANCE
BENCHMARKS WE ARE ASKING THAT
THE LEGISLATURE. CONTINUE TO
CLOSELY TRACK THE PROGRESS OF
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THESE
BENCHMARKS AND TAKE PROACTIVE
AND PREEMPTIVE ACTION IF
NECESSARY TO ENSURE THAT
LICENSEES CAN ACTIVELY
DILIGENTLY CONTINUE TO PURSUE
THE REQUIREMENTS FOR ANNUAL
LICENSES AS PROJECTED. FURTHER
WE CONTINUE TO ADVOCATE FOR
COMPREHENSIVE ASSESSMENT OF THE
STATE LICENSING FRAMEWORK TO
PURSUE STRUCTURAL REFORMS THAT
LOWER BARRIERS TO ENTRY
PERSPIRING SMALL BUSINESSES AND
SMALL ARMS SEEKING LICENSURE
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO MAKE A COMMENT ON AB AT THE.
ONE SIXTY TODAY HOUSE. THANK
YOU RYAN SIXTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN MEGAN ON BEHALF OF
HEALTH PLUS ADVOCATES IN THE
COMMUNITY AND CENTERS JUST ONE
TO EXPRESS OUR- FOR AB ONE
THIRTY THREE AND SPECIFICALLY
BE TELEHEALTH PROVISIONS OF THE
BILL EXTENDING THE CURRENT.
FLEXIBILITY PREVENTIVE FORBID
TO HEALTH CARE- IN PARTICULAR
TO COMMUNITY HEALTH CENTERS TO
PROVIDE A TELEHEALTH SERVICES
AND TELEHEALTH SERVICES VIA
PHONE ONLY AS WELL- THE
TEMPORARY FLEXIBILITY IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT TO THE
STABILITY OF THE HEALTHCARE
SYSTEM WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING ON THIS AGAIN- NEXT
YEAR FOR A MORE PERMANENT
SOLUTION BUT THANK YOU. AND
YOURSTAFF WITH A SPECIAL SHOUT
OUT TO SUB ONE SUB ONE STAFF
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU OPERATOR
ANY OTHER PUBLIC COMMENT IN THE-
ZERO. OKAY SEEING NONE WE WILL
ADJOURN THANK YOU OPERATOR.